all right people we are live on the
YouTube we're live-streaming we lost our
live streaming capabilities a couple
days ago we don't know why I don't have
an email address of anyone at YouTube I
look forward to getting one one day but
apparently we're live right now and I'm
with whoa
mr. Twitter mr. Twitter that's what I
just tweeted out ICO disaster Twitter
after what happened I'm Rogan yah yeah
yeah
I'm calling you mr. Twitter Tim Poole
I'm it was crazy for me after you know
I'm assuming everybody knows that I was
on with Jack and Joe and for me I'm just
having conversation like the cameras
don't exist I'm sitting here listen what
they have to say I'm trying to be
respectful make sure they finish their
point not let them go too far because
there are a few times where I was like
you can't you're lying but after the
fact all these videos were like Tim
Poole destroys you know and I'm like I
didn't feel like I was just showing them
I just felt like we were in conversation
you know yeah I felt like they were
listening at least Jack was Tim this is
the Internet
yeah if you even engage in a remotely
decent conversation that someone someone
gets just destroyed temple there will be
several destructors yeah okay so you
were on with with Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey who most people know what he was
on rogue in about a month ago he's been
embarrassed his podcast and a bunch of
others he agreed to do this show two
years ago I've emailed in mozillian
times and I tweeted hi yeah yeah no
they're trying to clear the schedule and
I he is welcome he would have been
welcome here today and all that you were
also on with Vijaya God eh
yeah who is from legal and trust and
safety at Twitter so it was the two of
them Rogen sort of moderating it and you
were kind of brought in well the Rhoden
has the muscle basically - I mean who
can kind of sit back and and you to just
pound on Jack Paar's lawyer yeah you
know and Joe Barba bunch of good points
but I think my favorite meme which which
described what happened was its it shows
Ash Ketchum and Gary from Pokemon with
two Pokemon underneath with my name and
vaginas name under it like right they
brought us both in to like get to the
nitty-gritty because you know here's the
thing in the first interview that Joe
did Joe didn't know a lot and neither
did Jack mm-hmm and I think I think it's
fair to point out Jack was running a ton
of companies and I respect him for going
on numerous times but I
it's important to point out most of the
questions I asked he'd defer to it you
know trust and safety yeah so all right
so let's just do a whole bunch of snap
here so I want to ask you the first
thing I'm gonna ask you is just how did
this whole freaking thing come together
because I was buying dog food yesterday
and then I suddenly saw a pop-up and I
was like how the hell is this happening
yeah no I knew you were coming in here
and I had no idea that it was going on
so so I want to ask you that but I just
want to say one thing quick off the bat
which is what you just said there hits
it on the head that it well all I saw
out of the two of them but mostly Jack
and I don't mean this to attack him or
her personally I mean as professionals
doing the job they're doing at Twitter
if you're gonna go on shows and talk
about these things that all it was was
endless kicking the can down the road
that you know how are you mean the buck
stops here I mean there was no there's
no buck and there's no stop it's like
we'll look into it oh that happened
we're not sure about that
we'll talk about it with this person
there's just it's just endless two
important things came out of the
conversation regardless of anything else
was when in two different instances I
pointed out if you were rule so so the
way I described it on Twitter is to a
conservative misgendering someone would
be if they were biologically male and
you called him a female pronoun and
progressives it's in the it's the
inverse if a trans woman wants use the
pronoun I pointed that at one of those
is factually correct we should what one
of them is actually on Wikipedia
consensus for the rest of society that
it is factually true but the the point I
want to make is not whether or not your
ideal ideology is correct or not correct
but that you do enforce an ideological
rule mm-hmm and she said thank you for
the feedback and then Joe and which
which she but then Joe made another
point and then her response was I think
that's absolutely correct Joe so I'm
glad that they admitted they do have a
bias and there were a few points where I
saw Jack have a look on his face so the
first thing was when they were pointing
out their rules I'd I interjected by
saying no no no your you actually have a
rule that's biased against conservatives
and Jack had this look where he was like
what what rule like he didn't realize it
you didn't eat it I'm like you realize
one of the top podcasts in the world Ben
Shapiro's show and ben shapiro disagrees
with you to tens of millions or more
they don't agree with that rule it makes
no sense to them and then i I you know I
tried to make a point about I looked it
up it's called body and
identity disorder these are people who
like ambit eight body parts I'm not
trying to equate the two but to point
out there are other similar syndromes
that aren't protected under the rules so
they do have the specific protected
class based on ideology so there was a
ton of moments like that where it seemed
like you were laying out some pretty
clear things that again they couldn't
they sort of were kind of evasive or we
don't know where we'll look into it
right yeah that's a lot of we'll look
into it and it's like alright we know
you're not really gonna look into it
because this it's not as if this it's
not as if Tim Poole as much as I respect
him Poole just magically came up with
all this stuff yesterday right like this
stuff's been out there for a while it
looks like the tweet I referenced his
gun I so I I specifically prepared this
I don't want to call it a stunt but I
was like I want to be able to pull this
up on cue so I set up a bitly link to
this tweeting question from September
that was daxing law enforcement never
taken down and people were tweeting jack
what's up with this there's articles
written about how it's never come down
and what they said is that they took
down some of the people that linked to
the tweet or something no no she just
said oh I don't know I don't you know we
make mistakes and and you know I will
say this too after the show Jack said my
two analogies about sand and snow were
really really important and he's gonna
understand what I sang by this and that
reference is if they keep making
mistakes the analogy I always use is how
many grains of sand until you have a
heap the heat of being biased against
conservatives and the snowflake
references Twitter thinks look we're
just one company we're making mistakes
they don't blame themselves for the fact
that all of these other companies are
doing the same thing it's an avalanche
and they're they're one of the
snowflakes the only way you change this
is when the individuals and the
companies take responsibility for what's
happening do you all right so hold on I
don't want to lose the crowd right how
the hell this thing came to be in that
runoff let that run at this point yet do
you think they actually care
Jaclyn's partly so alright well you were
the one sitting across yes I want to
know you I want to know your thoughts on
that but i partly was just like these
guys know exactly what they're doing we
know that conservatives get banned and
shadow band and unfollowed and all these
things all and it's not just
conservatives by the way cuz it's people
like yeah it's it's it's right you're
not a conservative right right
exactly so but that basically they go on
these shows even though it was sort of
impressive that the legal person showed
up that they're just going on just again
to kick the can down the road because it
gives a glimmer of hope for people to be
like see they care they're kind of doing
their thing but even though we know
nothing's gonna change right and that's
exactly how we ended it I'm like Here I
am sitting here Jack you're justifying
why everything you're doing is right I'm
trying to justify why what you're doing
is wrong and that's the end that's
nothing's gonna change and so so for me
I'm looking at the the opening gateway
that the bridge to the nightmare
dystopia when I see conservatives being
banned from bank accounts yeah from you
know patreon is one thing but that
PayPal's another then chase actually has
people down MasterCard you know
according to patreon MasterCard actually
wanted to get Robert I think Robert
Spencer and I'm like this is happening
you realize that real Stein is doing it
on a grand scale and we're watching the
start of it the Avalanche is kicking off
and these companies like I don't want to
you know none of the other companies
will show up but Twitter is going we're
doing that we're doing our best
Jack outlined this vision of a future to
me and he was and I'm like you're
describing the opposite direction to
where you're going he's you know like I
can't remember talked he was saying but
he was talking about open you know
everyone can speak and all these things
and just laying out the four principles
of what makes healthy conversation and
I'm like you realize you're actually
walking away from what you're describing
and you know I will say this too
ultimately what I feel like was kind of
happening isn't is that you tell
utilitarian versus the ontological
debate which for those that are familiar
Jack was convinced that he must do the
most good that means some he's looking
at the collective and saying how can I
make sure that 90 percent out of a
hundred people are sharing their
thoughts and I look at this and say the
individual needs to be allowed to speak
so out of a hundred people I'm like each
individual needs to be able to speak and
we can't do it we can't protect
everybody and that's why I asked Jack
when he said we did research and that's
why we implemented this trans rule I
said why did you stop there mmm ways
that he didn't I'm like but look if
you're gonna implement the rule to
protect one class of people we can look
at suicide rates for dentists we can
look at suicide rates for police are you
gonna make police a protected class
right or or if you're saying okay well
you can't misgender trans people well
can you call Jews Nazis as I got called
right Nazi by several guards offensive I
I think to verified people today and I
tweet Anna and I don't care I mean not
like that's that's not fun but right so
I get it because if you're if you're
basically a functioning human being that
is in a hysterical nut bag right exactly
right like basically I don't run around
reporting everybody I call it out
occasionally G and I'm only doing it to
show the double standard not to get
these people kicked off so it's a
reaction yeah to just say you you look
what you guys are doing I mean by any
estimation what they laid out yesterday
in terms of targeted harassment that
that'll get you booted and the whole
Milo thing and we can get into that yeah
well these people that today we there
were two verified people calling us
fascists and Nazis and a bunch of others
and that and then that harassment
escalates to extreme degrees yeah and
there are certain personalities that I
don't want to name that have made fake
videos and gotten people banned because
of it yeah so the challenge in calling
out the specifics is that they want
attention there and then when you name
them they they point the finger I have
no problem calling out like
organizations like I mentioned the SPLC
and hope not hate I'm doing it again
yeah I know that's gonna lead to yeah
but it you mean the southern property
hate center right oh whatever you want
to call it yeah I'll try I'll try to
it's s pH D is it now I'm gonna I'm
gonna try and be I'll call them up for
the areas but I won't do I won't do ride
like calling insulting their name or
anything yeah I know they're horrible i
I think they're bad simply but I will
say this the only thing I can really say
in terms of my personal interaction with
them is that they broke this article
that claimed I was attending a Holocaust
deniers conference in Iran and they used
a holocaust denying conspiracy theory
website to prove it if that's their
standard of proof that's nightmarish
especially when they are consulting
certain groups or they're involved with
change the terms org which wants to you
know do all these things they did
retract that though and they apologized
and called me an individual on the Left
yeah so I okay there you go right well
that's their I mean mod you know right
had to sue them to get them off his
anti-muslim extreme well he did but
Muslim but here's the here's the
important thing on extremists they
settled based on a strongly worded
letter I don't believe it ever actually
got to the point where a suit was filed
so they recognized they overstepped
their boundaries in my case and magics
case there
people they don't get that saying that
you know I'm not as big as [ __ ] or
even you but I'm fortunate enough to at
least have some you know notoriety that
provides me with protection like to to
try and call me all right is the most
insane thing ever and the weird thing is
it's white progressives doing it yeah
like my mixed-raced family who had races
actually attack us and the white
progressives who are well-off are the
ones who are pointing the finger at me
it's like you people are racist that's
all I can say
I mean well that that is the new
pernicious races yeah the left but okay
let's pause for dry right we're going
let's get back to the beginning how the
hell did this thing even happen because
when I saw it I'm sitting in the parking
lot and I was like well because because
it's like if you if they were trying to
protect their asses it's like the last
person you'd want to sit in there with
is you because if you would have said to
me who's the right guy to take them down
a notch I would have said you there
might have been a couple other guys but
I do
you'd be right in the center right the
right person that gets all of this I
feel lucky it's it's a decently it's not
super long but so here's what happens
Joe Rogan does the video with pot with
Jack Dorsey make it slammed yeah I make
a video about it saying like I watched
the podcast I was excited at first it
quickly got boring and then I kind of
just trailed off and felt like Joe
wasn't actually getting into anything
and you know we were better off for him
doing the interview by a tiny degree but
ultimately I don't think we gained
anything from it basically because he
didn't get into the nitty-gritty yeah it
was really it was Joe by any of them no
no but he knows this right it was it was
a really surface level regurgitation of
what we had already heard a million
times and so when Joe responded to the
complaints yeah I made a follow-up video
where I was like I respect you for doing
this Joe recognizes he's gonna you know
I criticized a bunch I before the video
I made went live because this was just
like I make rant videos on my second
channel they do way better than my more
like structured videos but before he
even went live I got a notification that
Joe Rogan or somebody Philly with him
had copyright flagged it and I was like
well Don this is a critic fair use so
fortunately several months ago Joe had
followed me on Twitter and apologized
for you know he canceled on me in the
past
and he was just like I feel bad about I
was it's it's a long time ago so now
we're now he's following me I just
tweeted at him and I said hey would you
mind releasing this it's fair use I was
criticizing your podcast and he's like
yeah send me the link and we'll go over
it I send in the link and then he
responds right away with like hey man
your criticisms were actually really
good can I call you right now and I was
like sure great and then he calls me and
then he kind of just explained like he
felt really bad that he didn't do a good
enough job he didn't realize how
important these issues work he just
thought he was meeting with like a tech
CEO and you know really follow a lot of
the stuff and then at the end of the cup
near the end of the call we talked for a
while he goes you know I owe you coming
out on the show man so I'll bring you
out sometime I'm like yeah sure haven't
have a good day five hours later
whatever I'm lucky my shorts playing
video games like end of the day but I go
to bed and my phone rings and it's Joe
and he goes you want to come on the show
on Friday and I'm like that's like I
gotta fly tomorrow that's like one day
like yeah and I'm like okay we go I go
on the show everybody saw it was great
and then immediately after the show he's
like he calls me up right when I get
back to my hotel and he says how would
you like to come on and do this thing
don't tell anybody
and it'll be you me Jack and he's gonna
bring on somebody and he says I'm trying
to confirm it so I think the main reason
he didn't want to promote it was he was
concerned that like it's hard to confirm
it's it's especially with someone as
busy as jack is so he's like I want to
make I want to hype it up I want to make
sure we actually do it otherwise
everyone's gonna get angry when we
cancel right you know so then I didn't
know was gonna happen and it wasn't
until like a few days ago where he not
enough that maybe like a week ago they
were like we're good to go we're gonna
fly you out and he was like I don't
think there's anything expressly like
don't promote it but just Joe was like
I'm gonna I'm gonna take care of that
Mike all right so I just didn't say
anything cuz I don't know what's gonna
happen right so that's why I think it's
so it's so interesting because a first
off I give Joe credit for going okay
this isn't my area of expertise per se
so let me bring in somebody that it is
so that there's a little bit of that
back and forth but be it partly brings
me back to what I said before which is
once they had heard I don't know when
they found out that you know Jack and in
advance okay so a couple let's say a
couple days before no no like a month
okay so a month yeah they look at the
lead time no way this Tim pool guy is
gonna be the one sitting
that it seems to me that the only reason
that they would agree to do it because
they had to assume it was gonna go
exactly as it went not well for them
know that it would the only reason you
do it is if it's just to kick the can
down the road
Thanks just you know you mean it's not
for justification yeah
I mean you could look at Vijaya had a
laptop with a bunch of research and and
and I there were there a couple
instances where I said she makes a good
point right there are some people she
mentioned this is why we banned them and
in some cases you know I brought up
Sargon of Akkad I didn't bring him Carl
Benjamin I don't bring him up to defend
it because I know he tweeted things that
it's like dude you really pushed buttons
but then inadvertently find out one of
them was very clearly pointing at their
they're biased ruleset and not actually
targeting anybody in any way in which
case they did end up you know false
striking him at least one time but they
did it they did their research a few
people but ultimately I think one point
we got out of that was we're just gonna
trust you like you haven't presented
this evidence to anybody you're saying
it now but there is an important detail
there that I want to stress too is that
everything she said about why they ban
people those are statements of fact and
if those aren't real and they can't
prove it they can be sued for defamation
so anybody who's now been banned by
Twitter that she mentioned should have
their lawyers going back well I'm not
saying do anything I'm just saying if it
cuz I Alex texted Joe apparently said
that's not true okay great Walt they
made a statement of fact on a show as to
why they took action against you saying
Alex Jones did X if that's not true
well now you can file your complaint
yeah see that's what I think the reason
I'm so it's not even frustrated I'm
actually not frustrated by it I'm so
like sort of blase about it is because
it's like I you know I had jack conte in
here the the patreon CEO like two years
ago and there he was sitting with me
telling me you know we'll never move
people yes whispering sweet nothings in
your ears that convinced you right and
it's it'll only will only boot people
because of manifests the observer
behavior mayor ma mo ba I can't make
this stuff up and and that's sort of
what I that was the feeling that I got
from this Jack Jack Dorsey that it's
just like we'll just say things and it
kind of don't keeps moving things along
here's what I think and again I'm not
I'm really not impugning him as a person
IV I I'll take your word for it
what no so so there are some
conservatives who are not super high
like
high-profile whatever that I've met in
the past and and someone told me a long
time ago not not super long ago recently
relatively recently within the past few
months that Jax actually not a bad guy
it's the people around him who are
telling these things and he's not
exposed to heard some insider stuff
exactly and so what ends up happening is
when I said your rule is biased against
conservative from the get-go
Jack genuinely looked confused and he
said well what rule and I had to explain
it to him but then maybe he shouldn't be
the CEO of the company I mean not to be
a dick it's he's the CEO of several
companies is that correct I believe so
yeah I mean you got cash up square
Witter I don't know all right so let's
just say Twitter is enough of a job in
and of itself like if you don't know the
rules like what are you doing right it's
not that he didn't know the rule said he
didn't because he talked about the
research they did for that rule it said
he didn't realize more than 50 about 50%
of this country actually it's way more
than that don't agree with it
ideological view and the reason I say
more than that is because moderate
liberals you know like I talked to my
mom and my mom is a lifelong liberal
know and she's she's a progressive she
agrees with so much of what the modern
left today agrees with and the new
progressives and but she said oh I don't
know if you know trans women should be
competing against biological women and I
said well hold your horses there mom
that's a conservative you know and so if
my mama liberal yeah it's still
questioning that then Twitter's very
clearly taking a very small minority
position on that if you've got a
feminist like Megan Murphy who's clearly
on the left being banned because she
doesn't want to adhere to this it's not
even a left versus right issue you've
got moderate liberals feminists
conservatives all saying we'll hold on
on this issue but Twitter's clearly
adopted a very ideological rule and not
Jack I don't think anyone's ever told to
Jack that and here's the thing yeah what
really don't think that though I don't
I'm with you on all this but so he so he
lives in some level of a bubble but none
of this very obvious stuff I mean what
you just laid out I mean I've been
talking about this for have you had five
heavy ters now you know what I mean it's
not like it's not like the internet
hasn't been like abuzz about this type
of conversation but no-one's got in I
haven't seen anyone actually break down
they say oh but hate speech that's not
fair
they say things like that and I'm not
going to know hold on there's a very
clear ideological divide between this
rule and everything else well
when it comes to hate speech very
obviously conservatives are you know
gung-ho on free speech and the many on
the Left aren't but that's still
different because it's like we just
don't want you to harass people and say
mean things and it's kind of been
normalized because all the platforms do
it but the misgendering thing is so
specific and and you know I'll say this
ooh I really hate using like they kind
of backing me into using this because I
don't necessarily disagree with why they
have the rule
like I think purposefully being
disrespectful targeting people
misgendering dead naming I don't I think
those are wrong at the same time you
have to recognize conservatives think
you're it's inverted for them right
right they think it's wrong to gender
someone they're not by Allah you know
that's not their biological gender and
my goal is look I'm a so we talked about
this the first time I'm a social liberal
not a classical liberal yeah but I
respect the right of other people to
have opinions and debate and share ideas
and try and figure out what works so I
will say listen this is what they think
and they're and they're arguing and you
don't see that and I genuinely believed
because I've seen the debates with the
conversations with Jack the testimony
from Congress no one has ever pointed
this out to him and he was kind of like
I think he kind of realized it I look at
Jackson I mean that me that to me that
makes it sound like he's an idiot I mean
I like I completely hear you and I'm not
I'm not judging your judgment and right
and actually it's just like I don't know
what job you're and then dude you should
have another job I think I think he's a
it's almost like he has say he is the
chief executive officer but it's I think
it's more of a he gets an email and goes
- sure you know that I mean yeah does
that sort of tell you though what social
justice does to a company that all this
could be going on and you sort of need a
head guy like it's true for any company
depending on big it is though you know
it's like Jack can only know so much but
I also think you have to look at I I
could be wrong on this Jack was fired
they were placed in with Dick Costolo
and then dick Isola left and then Jack
came back so it may just be that they
were like bring him back in it's gonna
be kind of a in paper like in name only
thing he does have authority obviously
he's talked about that but I think he's
not super focused right and again I'm
not attacking the guy it's like I want
him to come in here and I would treat
him with as much respect as I would
anyone else so okay well yeah good well
I think the only reason these
conversations happen is because of him I
think he you know he follows I'm pretty
sure he follows Jordan Peterson I think
he follows you
so I think he genuinely is trying to
understand why people are mad at him and
that's why after the podcast he said the
grains of sand thing makes a lot of
sense like to him he was probably
thinking we just made mistakes man and I
say right but each of those mistakes
makes a huge pile and people are
pointing to the pile and you're going
but it's a mistake it's a mistake no
it's a pile dude yeah I think huge heap
you keep doing it it's a pretty big heap
so okay so when see there was a lot of
the conversation that was about while
more of this seems to be happening to
conservatives but you did point out
actually that sometimes they've banned
some left the accounts right yeah yeah
no it's not a lot but there there have
been some there's a decent amount of so
I would say it's the lower tier accounts
across the board if it's really freaking
- it's the anti-war left is getting a
ton of heat but they're not particularly
popular or mainstream so there's no one
coming out to defend them conservatives
when they hear about it will be like hey
that's not cool but it's not an you know
so so Occupy Wall Street accounts have
been banned by Twitter for I have no
idea why they never missed it this got
rid of like 56 accounts some with like
50,000 followers so the activists left
that are not the same as the edge' to
Tyrion like high-profile regressive left
people these are people predominantly
focused on Venezuela and Syria and like
get you know end the war they don't have
the mainstream pull from the left to
defend them and the information isn't
traveling to conservative circles I see
it you know somebody at Michelle Malkin
tweeted you know this this Silicon
Valley lobbyists said it happens to the
left to but couldn't name a single
person and then I named three
organizations that have been hit
recently mm-hmm I think it's fair to
point out for everyone anti-war leftist
you get like 30 conservatives right so
that's why I was asking you the question
cuz I don't want people to think that
it's nobody on the left because it's not
nobody but in terms of proportion it
seems to be far worse and it's not far
right I mean that's the thing it's not
far right now it's not sargon of akkad
crawl benjin may have broken their rules
by targeted harassment or whatever
whatever saying Craig he said some crazy
stuff whatever he did I'm not I'm not
defending it or whatever but it's like
the idea that he's far-right in my mind
is crazy like guys well you know he's a
bit of a troll but he's basically an
old-school liberal or you know
sargon and daniela they joined you Kip
yeah and so even though you know like
daniela has a communist star on his
chest and he his political compass is
slightly center-left it's like you join
a conservative or right-wing party then
like i don't know how you did say you're
not to right-wing sure but he's like
that in and of itself isn't a reason to
get booted off a platform well of course
not but but Sargon said a bunch of stuff
and he even messaged me he was like he
was saying like oh man your face when
you realize like what I said
so yeah that's like he said so he said
some pretty crazy things man yeah you
know do you think it's possible I I'm
sort of coming to this belief that we're
about to watch one if not more of these
giant tech companies completely crumble
within the next two years that the
platform's have grown to the point where
nobody can control them anymore this is
where I would give you a little I would
give Jack let's say a little bit of a
leash and not understanding what's going
on yeah but they've all grown so big
there are so many people on them there
are so many BOTS and targeted accounts
and all of these things and competing
interests and people who believe in free
speech and people who don't and you know
governments like Pakistan who are trying
to get Twitter to take down people for
their blasphemy laws and then Twitter an
American company actually does it well I
don't think they take anybody down
do they not take it and actually agree
with Twitter on this one they notify you
yeah
so I've seen a lot of conservatives who
are upset that have gotten this
blasphemy notice and I'm like oh oh hold
on Twitter so you a favor if you could
be killed if you go to Pakistan now if
you put if you bought violate Pakistan
law I would appreciate it if Twitter
told me hey just FYI they want to kill
you so don't go there
right it's it's a guess no Twitter
hasn't taken any adverse action against
these the people who have posted
pictures of Mohammed they've just said
we want to let you know Pakistan has
filed a complaint against you and you
may want legal representation
to deal with it that I agree with that
they're giving you a government notice
we want the transparency of the company
it's up those images or whatever images
they are they are up in in Twitter and
Pakistan they're taking they're taken
down to Pakistan so taken right so
that's where it's an American company
see this is where I would say an
American company should but should
operate on the laws of America in
America though I mean it's it's tough
this is one of the debates to about
cultural imperialism should and this is
one of things I was asking to to Jack
because I know they in for
blasphemy laws in other countries it's
it's the you must follow the laws of the
countries they're in but I ask them does
your hate speech policy apply to Iran
they pour clarified them they're blocked
in around I'm like okay what about you
know Pakistan a country where it's
illegal to be gay do will you if so it's
it's a weird circumstance yeah let's
pull up there's a ton of countries where
it's illegal to be gay let's say someone
is convicted of sodomy or homosexuality
and then you go on Twitter and target
them and say you're a dirty criminal
you're awful will Twitter ban you
because then you have a weird conundrum
of the citizen following the law of his
own country being banned by Twitter even
though Twitter has to follow a law of
that country - it's a weird now I
personally would be on Twitter site on
that one like that's horrifying what
they do in those countries at the same
time Twitter is imposing its cultural
values on foreign countries where it's
supposed to be following their laws it's
it's it's I mean yeah to me I mean look
and I'm not a CEO of a giant tech
company but that's where I would just
say we're a United States company and
we're gonna follow the free speech laws
of the United States and if then the
country wants to stop you from being on
there well then they can do what they
want and they often do as this is but
this is this is this is why freedom
we're gonna start seeing like a
nightmare
you know scenario of dystopia what what
their response to me in how their rules
supersede US law is that well we're a
global company and I'm like right but
you have a platform that is extremely
extremely powerful in influencing our
elections and this is the most important
point people don't seem to understand
I've seen so much criticism I know
they're out the people out there don't
seem to understand what I'm saying
they're like Tim doesn't understand that
free speech doesn't give you a right to
a private platform absolutely right well
I'm a social liberal who believes in
regulation that recognize when a company
becomes so powerful it starts becoming a
detriment to your democratic republic
and your institutions the government
must intervene that's my opinion yeah so
you're taking a Trump position on this
actually drop position
yeah well Trump wants basically the
government to get involved at this point
well I mean I don't I mean that's a
pretty conservative position not mine
yeah so socially liberal regulation of
major companies oh well it's become
conservative now because now you it's
not oh I'm so weird what you hear is oh
well this shows you how everything's
flipped right yes you here now
conservative saying
it's gotten to the point where we're
gonna go against what our core belief is
I don't fall in that I still it's crazy
human ingenuity but it annoys me when
people respond to like the Joe Rogan
podcast saying like these conservatives
they scream small you know private
business and small government up until
they get banned and I'm like I have
always been in favor of regulating
companies that are breaking rules I used
to work for environmental organization
so with you before the government
regulating Twitter right now at this
point absolutely I and and this is only
after the conversation with Jack because
seeing the you know III respect it would
be for the Trump government I mean which
I assume you're not a big Trump guy you
would be not a government definitely not
before the government led by Donald
Trump to regulate Twitter it's not just
led by Trump Exxon do Castillo Cortes
isn't how she got 3.5 million followers
so she has influence that's worse sure
sure but there's an issue here yeah if
you know one of the things I said to
them was if you are unwilling to uphold
I I didn't say it as clearly as I've
thought about I tweet about if you're
unwilling to uphold the legal standard
of public discourse set by the rules of
the Supreme Court in the Unites States
Constitution then you will face
regulation and their unwillingness to do
so in full full well knowing foreign
governments aren't manipulating us to
trick us into voting for knowing that
new knowledge was involved in the scheme
to do Russian BOTS to cost the
Republicans an election that that's
terrifying me to me and I would rather
see Twitter turned off right now switch
done yeah if it meant we're gonna
protect our democracy our Democratic
Republic because every week it's mad at
me representative Republic through
democratic institutions do you think in
a weird way that the Twitter people Jack
included want that that they argue I
think yeah that they've realized and
maybe that's why they're doing this
little press thing right now they've
realized they can't control the Beast
anymore so what would be the best thing
Jerry solution Jarett Jerry rules uh so
what they do on periscope and Jack
mentioned this is you'll get a
notification is this comment okay yeah
and I always say yes for the most part
like unless you said something something
like an excitement Devon to break the
law I'm pretty much like yeah you got a
stupid opinion but it's fine
Twitter to do the same thing it absolves
them of responsibility it clears the
bias sample a hundred thousand random
people in the country of the origin of
tweet
and then let them decide so when Vijaya
yesterday was saying you were let's do
it the other way when these guys this
morning called us Nazis and fascists and
whatever this usual nonsense that comes
out to talk about yeah and with us um do
you think that would be a violation of
the rules that she laid out yesterday
verified accounts labelling people to
get their people to attack you as I mean
he one of these guys called you a Nazi
propagandist and I think he should be
like I'm a fascist I'm for him being
allowed to as well but I'm saying by the
loop by the rules that she laid out
yesterday do you think that should be
allowed on their platform by her rules
not not your free speech rules um the
problem is their rules are arbitrary I
think you know we saw a guy post a
picture of Mike Stern eviction his
underwear and the first time he did it
he got a lock out second time nothing
happened just my understanding so that's
shocking to me I don't care where the
photo came from people are saying like
oh it was on a public web site I don't
care you took a photo of somebody in a
compromising position and posted it
without their permission like that's
crazy that Twitter allows that can't say
I'm surprised their harassment campaigns
have been going on for years against
conservatives that Twitter does nothing
about so am I surprised that this could
be a violation of the rules if you do it
to someone else
of course Twitter would ban you if you
were doing it to people play you know
you look at you look at we're getting we
got a symmetry problem well exactly I
mean you look at why when she read the
first tweet from Sargon as to why he got
banned and he was saying he said a bunch
of things like about white people and
men these things are not hate speech
according to Twitter he wasn't saying it
to anybody directly he was saying these
phrases are not hate speech
and Twitter said is it as ban well
that's why it's so engine so that's why
people like us and where free speech
people are so frustrated with this
because it's like look you can clearly
call a Jew and not see there it's no
problem yeah but if you called a black
person the n-word and obviously I'm not
for doing that you'd be booted in a
second anyone yeah now you can argue
whether well I would to do that or not
there's there's objective nature of it
there's a slur for for Jewish people
that support supported the Germans yeah
part of the K and I oppose well I want
to say it I
is that allowed yeah I Drive but I know
the livestream probably just went down
I've seen a bunch of people on the left
using that calling PBOT I'm like dude
that's a slur like that's that's a rat's
an ethnic slur against too much people
man how is that not being how do these
I'm like you know what here's my thing
they know they have that extra layer of
protection I mean right something funny
happened at the end of the stream we did
where apparently didn't go down so joe
said we're done the mics were hot and
now there's a conspiracy going around as
to what I was talking about some people
have incredibly pointed out truth like
they're what really happened and some
people are getting conspiratorial after
we ended vijaya asked me for the names
she said what was the anti fat wheat
that did that docks the cops and I said
it's I gave her the link it's it's down
now it was bit ly / auntie 4 tweet I
believe it took it down she said and can
you give me the names of the accounts
that were threatening her said no I
believe in minimizing harm it's an
ethics a part of the journalistic ethics
where my primary concern is that after
lauren southern got taken down from
patreon a lot of conservatives and we're
like pointing to it's going down saying
why aren't they being taken down but
asymmetrical I retied Jack Conte and
said there's accusations of a symmetry
based on these accounts and Jack
immediately immediately banned it's
going down hmm so now I said ah whoa
that was bad I did not want the tappet
right from from this point on I will
never give a name of these companies so
they can take action against people who
I'm at odds with that would be me using
my weight for personal gain once the
stream ended she asked me for names I
said no I began to explain when Lauren
Southern got taken down then Joe's like
everybody out
so to two narratives purged the first I
can already see the first was that a
true and this is this is what most
people sharing Tim Poole maintained his
journalistic integrity even we didn't
know the mics were alive and I'm like oh
that's like that's that's sweet I see
like I'm like happy accident some people
are claiming that I'm refusing to share
the names because they're fake and I
made it all up
like when ended up happening was after
we left the room she asked me for the
names and I was like which names
specifically though like what do you ask
me I'm not gonna ban them or anything I
want to know who was saying it to you
and I was like I don't know your talk
about which specific particularly to all
the people threatening you and I was
like oh that was three three years
through like two or three years ago it
was just some auntie [ __ ] count yeah I
can't remember then it wasn't anybody
high-profile is there a weird thing
so we're that getting people banned or
let's say the people are threatening you
with violence or I've had people
threaten me with Anza you know like some
fairly serious things and that's the
only time I've really ever reported
every now and again some of the rights
I'm really vile like like truly like
really vile usually some gay reference
and I'll report it just to see if
Twitter does something about yeah
because I'm just trying they don't the
thing and they don't yeah but but the
few times that I've gotten what I think
are seemingly legit dats they have
gotten rid of the accounts but then
after they do it and I get the email
back and it's like we've suspended this
account err terminate this account I'm
always like did I just accomplish
anything there because if anything
unless that person was then unless they
used an IP address and I wouldn't before
any of this but unless they actually
track down who this person was well now
we've just enraged somebody who had a
lot of rage beforehand yeah so we
probably just exacerbated you yeah so
the I used to never block anybody yeah I
would just mute people who are incessant
and bad faith actors but then I decided
out of sight out of mind
so although blocking someone doesn't
prevent them from ever seeing your
tweets it makes it much more much less
likely they'll see your tweet yeah you
know so I was like there's there's
certain people I've blocked I think I've
blocked maybe like 25 people bad faith
actors who wait for tweet they can pull
out of context like some of the people
from yesterday with Joe Rogan they take
screenshots they lie about what was said
but they know that their followers
enable affect will net will never fact
check yeah so then they just push that
lie I believe that people are allowed to
be crazy and stupid so the people who
are like the guy who's accusing me of
being a far-right conspiracy this and
whenever I think he's lying I think he
knows full well because that guy used to
DM me and he was asking me to like cover
certain issues up until I called him out
for posting the the threatening to post
revenge porn of certain of it now he's
angry and I was lying he says about me
I'll make this clear yeah
so people are probably they probably
know who this guy is cuz there's a meme
going around of me saying journalists
are gonna do this then he does this just
to be clear this guy was asking me to
cover stories for him up until he got
mad at me and now he's claiming I'm
far-right is asking me for help is that
me that he regularly deems far-right
conspiracy theorists that he's thinker
acting in bad faith for help well this
is the problem and there's the other guy
who was like I used to be Tim Poole's
roommate straight-up lie he posted a
straight-up lie and I'm like
let me to post the DMS yeah I can prove
your line so is business so let's take
this to a different meta level for a
second out of Twitter for just a moment
but do you think this the basic the
basic quest for truth let's say that
some people are on versus just the rest
of this crew that wants to just watch
scorched earth or just destroy
everything that that really is what the
cultural war is about because you and I
have pretty significant political
differences and it is clear and I know
and correct me if I'm wrong it's it's
irrelevant to me I think it's irrelevant
to you you know we could we can do those
discussions and we've done them before
yeah I don't think we do them now
because there's so many other things to
talk about but it's like I think we both
know that we're on basically the same
quest for something that's true right
right he said that we want people to
live free but but that's what the
culture war really is about it's that
you've got this little sliver of people
trying really trying and we're dealing
with people that basically act like like
Heath Ledger's Joker I think I think
wanted to burn but I think they're
sociopaths left in the right scotum
there are people that I believe on the
left and the right [ __ ] grifters I
don't know which side has more or less I
don't publicly call people as grifters
because I can never prove even to myself
I'm like I think something about that
person I don't trust them but now that
would be really unfair to accuse them of
being disingenuous on things that
they're truly passionate about but I
think what we have kind of in the
culture war is you know I saw something
on Twitter where there's this activist
who works for NBC and he's literally
activist he's lobbied Twitter for
actions so I can't call him a journalist
and he was claiming that everyone who
criticized Captain Marvel or brie Larson
was an insult he's did a piece on it
today and I'm like you clay you can't
clearly think that every single person
is not getting laid that's a really
you're very clearly trying to trigger
and attack people but the important
point was that for the record I'm
getting late and I have no desire to see
it well yeah but so the point well you
know I tried bringing up just calmly to
one it was a buzz reporter who quoted it
I didn't argue for or against I said
here's what people are thinking and his
response was that I was engaged in
far-right propaganda and I've lost my
mind and I'm like he was like I don't
see any of these conversations on Reddit
therefore it's far-right propaganda
YouTube was dominated by far-right
propaganda and
like I realized something because
someone commented this reddit is
moderated particularly by the companies
you know they will they want to make
sure they're promoting their content and
there's very few things that can appear
but YouTube is a very libertarian
platform where whatever works works very
meritocratic yeah
so when YouTube if your video is good
and entertaining people watch it what
does that mean well they're not in cells
it means that a lot of people are
watching these videos and YouTube is
saying if people like it we're gonna
show it that's not a rabbit hole of
conspiracy theories it's a lot of these
videos Chris Hansen Captain Marvel very
simply people saying I'm sure the movie
will do well I'm sure it's gonna be like
a moderately good Marvel film I just
don't like brie Larson because she's
very snooty and condescending I'm gonna
sit this one out
yeah there are some people who are
completely how I feel right I love all
the Marvel movies right boom event
infinity war was I think the best one
how great yeah best one I can't wait for
the next one and I have no desire to see
it cuz I saw her little speech and it's
like you know what I just don't want to
support you if we keep supporting these
people who are so contrary to at least
the things that I believe in it's like
the only way you're gonna ever get
change because I don't want the
government to stop them I want I want
them to stop themselves but so here's
the thing I don't I don't feel that way
for me it's kind of that they marketed
the movie as a big feminist film brie
Larson's own words the commercial has a
big her in the screen and then a and
appears as a hero and I'm like I see
where they're going with this ice at
their Ghostbusters ice at the last Jedi
I'm gonna sit this one out until the
reviews come in I got no beef with
Marvel or brie Larson I don't like the
things she says but Chris Evans Captain
America says crazy things too well Mark
Ruffalo makes me write like this oh I
can separate the art from the artist
yeah but when your marketing is
overwhelmingly reminiscent of
Ghostbusters in last gen I'm gonna I'm
gonna wait yeah and I'm hearing it's
boring um you know it's got like a 6.6
on Metacritic and even left-wing outlets
are saying it's mediocre and boring at
best so I'm like maybe I won't see it
you know well it definitely was the Nazi
trolls that that's good and that's the
crazy thing there at the ratings they're
already think they're already seeding
that there's an outlet that wrote a
story saying trolls are right right-wing
trolls are preparing a campaign to
destroy the ratings and their story was
we saw one person on Twitter who said
let's do this and I was like yeah how
many apparently had no followers I'm
like Rand
Twitter how did you make it like it
cares what but that's why this also is
so strange to me because we can see
these trends all over the place so
remember when there was that video of
Acacio cortez dancing nobody cares and
then nobody care complimented her I saw
all all the Conservatives were let all
of them all the verified conservatives
that if any following of note were like
oh this is kind of cute or I don't like
her but she's a human Bubba and then but
all this all the Conservatives going
crazy any most of them they didn't link
to anything where they would link to an
anonymous account that you don't even
know it was one account yeah that's it
was that Newsweek which one it was it
was anonymous no I know but what what
paid what outlet oh that article oh I
don't know but they were it was everyone
your times what about yeah when I first
saw that video I left and I said I tweet
something like wow this makes her seem
really relatable and endearing yeah it's
really it's I said it makes her look
like she's fun and I come like it was
like a compliment I'm like I'm like wow
that's that's really cool that we have
this video of like a college fun time
they were recreating Breakfast Club
dances I mean I'm I don't I I know that
those people will lump me in with
conservatives I don't think of me that
way but their first response I saw from
literally everybody was like lol this is
so funny like it's fun haha but then
when you see that at the political level
and we see it all the time at sort of a
gamer level or the Twitter level or
whatever you realize that these these
themes like it doesn't take a genius to
put some of this together but alright
let's let's shift a little bit so first
up we're gonna do we'll do like an hour
of Q&A from the audience yeah yeah you
down for that whatever we're gonna do
that but I want I want to do a bunch
more here first but people can submit on
on the super chat right now let's talk
about my favorite organization in
America even more I like these guys even
more than the Southern Poverty hate
Center Oh add in society oh the
conspiracies a little bit about dad in
society they put up a chart the
alternative influencer name well they're
directly associated when they do they're
directly connected to the daily stormer
yeah that's a fact and I've mentioned
this in the past and people on the Left
had the same reaction that we have to
their conspiracy theory crime web and
actually the connection between date and
society to neo Nazism is extremely
direct relative to what they claimed so
one of their advisors has explained what
data is ID yeah so data society is it's
a new york-based think-tank of
progressives that are
tracking data social media and how it
impacts society and they do a lot of
research looking into far-right and
Russian interference one of the people
so this is great and I hope I hope
they're listening I have an insider
who's been feeding the information and I
know they're working on like a Russian
document right now and the woman who's
writing it tweets every three minutes
about some nonsensical conspiracy theory
and I laughed I'm like it represents
them very well but I hope they're
listening and they know that I've got
somebody inside their organization has
sent me like so I also know that they've
admitted the connections in their report
the alternative influence network
they're a direct quote sent to me was
some of these are not factual so I have
you know and that's and that's how I
admitted to you that the report was I
want to say there won't errors related
but you know I mean basically I just a
bunch of names I'll say this I have been
fed insider information and one of the
statements given to me by an individual
not from them but through someone
associated in certain capacity I'm
trying to be very careful not to expose
yeah was a quote some of these are not
factual and there's more there but that
was that was it but you know yeah so
ultimately I just you know whatever
right but what's interesting about it is
it's not just whatever because we then
see how these studies that were based in
nothing other than oh this person
appeared with this person or this person
did a livestream at this person and then
you link it together and it looks like
some sort of massive network of scheming
together and the connections are fake
most of some of them were connections
were often fake but not only that there
was no evidence but the whole premise of
it this alternative influence network
was that this group of people that
included sam Harris and Jordan Peterson
and you and me and a whole bunch of
others that we've radicalized people to
the far right when in fact there is
actual data right that reject data has
shown that I've actually redeem
radicalized people of the right and made
the more liberal in a lot of cases and
I've actually not that antidote evidence
is enough in it but I have a lot of
evidence more but more importantly it
claims that YouTube channels okay Sam
Harris to see the YouTube channel I'm
yes yes but they also mentioned James
d'amour who at the time there was there
was four people listed that weren't
youtubers some that were on YouTube with
like a thousand subscribers that posted
one or two
videos at some point and I'm like that's
a fake that's fake narrative but I wanna
make something absolutely clear that
thing that I had muted on Twitter
because I can't work they're going after
me and the report is implying that we're
like you know oh yeah and and and and
they tried to get into that they tried
to dance around the nuance of
understanding that one of the problems
was they said these people hold views
from libertarian to mainstream
conservative libertarian to white
nationalist I don't fit that bracket at
all
absolutely not yeah simply because I
defend you're not a white nationalist oh
yeah my mixed-race family would fit
really really well into a one-note sort
of Oh it's half Korean quarter Karine
actually yeah yeah so here's the
important thing one of the advisors who
did in society has appeared on numerous
podcasts and praised the former web dev
from The Daily stormer she was heavily
criticized for this has tried coming out
and making like you know oh no no it's
just my research but there's a podcast
from I believe it may be from WNYC where
she's talking about know this neo-nazi
guy it's all just jokes it's all just
LOLOL the big swastika on his chest and
all these things it's just funny haha
and that's that's one of their advisors
so if they want if they want to lay
accusations towards me because I would
you not one of their accusations was
that in a video someone walked past me I
was at a party at VidCon where there's
thousands of people I've never met I
showed up to do an interview with a guy
and as someone's interviewing talking to
me on their camera someone was like
walked in after the fact and she says
that connects them it's like okay I
never had a word to that person I've
never met them I just saw them at a
party won't even shake hands your
organization has an advisor who has
appeared on shows and praised an actual
neo-nazi well depending on who you ask
let's say he's not really a neo-nazi I
don't want to drag people by naming them
but it's an individual who's one of the
most notorious Charles on the planet was
associated with daily stormer has a
swastika on their chest I'll leave it
there and I will point out to people who
know the woman and this man will say
it's unfair to characterize them in that
manner but if we're going by the
standard set by data in society right
there you literally have a woman who's
written a book and defended to the
extent where said it's just a joke it's
just a game it's it's it's funny well
tell that to that
they should tell it to themselves if
they think it's funny to get a tattoo of
a swastika on your chest and to make
horrifying jokes about marginalized
communities that's their standard for
what's funny or at least one of their
advisors I have to question their
motives when they want to accuse me of
being a gateway to anything maybe should
look internally you know clean your
house clean your room before trying to
change the world right it's right over
there
exactly what do you make of the fact the
way that okay so these reports come out
and then immediately
HuffPo Daily Beast everybody jumps on
board them Vox did a big piece on it
Ezra Klein even tagged me in the tweet
devoting the article to me oh yeah that
they all then I'd use it as oh we've got
evidence of it and what I evidence of
that these these are the alt-right
radicalist and that you know you're
making turning people into white
nationalists and I'm turning people into
alma folk do some some ridiculous
nonsense but what I think is most
fascinating about it is it's like if you
look at the people in that group most of
them are sort of self funded or patreon
or youtubers some of them probably have
other jobs meanwhile Vox is funded by
like hundreds of millions each year and
then you see money yeah I mean like and
feel the need to go after Chris Raygun
who is a freaking Burnie burns
he's a birdie brother video game so it
shows you that the power really is
shifted where they know it's like their
lives and their who you're losing you
know what annoyed me about the Ezra
Klein thing he said this really is the
reactionary right and I'm like I made a
documentary an hour-long documentary
bout institutional racism I have only
ever defended social justice policy in
terms of the problems of institutional
racism the importance of protecting
marginalized communities my issue is
that I'm on the libertarian spectrum
towards the left these are people who
are hippie pot-smoking sand on the beach
with dreads and chill these are the
people I aligned with skateboarders we
want to be left alone but we're all
friends we want to have hugs and we
wanna have vegan food people have known
my whole life so we're we're the kind of
people who are like no no man like we
should we should do the best to
cooperate and end these oppressive
things but you silencing other people
you accusing other people smearing them
attacking them and being racist are
things I don't agree with Linda Sarsour
was just dragging Nancy Pelosi for being
a white feminist who supports a white
patriarchy and I'm like yes I agree that
we should respect all peoples of
different faiths and
national origins gender @nd etc you're
not doing that you are literally trying
to weaponize the color of this woman's
skin if there's a racist in the equation
its Linda Sarsour I mean exactly yeah so
how is it that that makes me reactionary
right when I'm actually in favor of
upholding the tenants of social justice
without being an authoritarian mean
person I'm gonna avoid swearing you know
here let's do the political thing quick
are you forgetting marriage yeah well
yeah of course me too okay that's pretty
Larry yeah again are you for abortion
you're pro-choice I'm pro-choice I'm Pro
- yeah - okay that seems pretty lefty
you know once there - are you guess the
death penalty absolutely I'm against the
death penalty to public education yeah
100% me - are you for euthanasia you can
do with death well you have a right to
decide at the end of year oh yeah yeah
that's a pretty lofty thing right right
and right to try was that the
experimental medications yeah I'll go
one step further than you that's more of
a libertarian thing I'm for progressive
tax I'm in favor of a minimum wage
both of these students come with caveats
yeah I believe against both of those
have gotta believe on the lefty run now
if you and I have I believe that we
should do student loan forgiveness yeah
I believe that there's a bunch of other
areas where there's a discussion there
yep yep so I can go on but it's like
this is it's it's crazy when I say I
supported Bernie and people like he's
lying
and I'm like watch my videos yeah I'll
point out the insanity of the green new
deal try that the second page of the
green new deal is like racial equity
equities not equality
why is my environmental bill being
plagued by 10 to terrian ism that makes
me angry
I like environmentalism I'm in favor of
environmental regulation yeah and I mean
I've been I've been on this in this
business of all of my life it's almost
like no Democrats yeah it's it's crazy
to me and the funny thing is I made a
video about Linda Sarsour dragging Nancy
Pelosi today and I thought it was funny
how like I've actually probably
complimented Nancy Pelosi even though I
don't like the corporatist mainstream
Democrats because I thought about it I'm
like well my only real gripe with her is
how she handles her business with Trump
not really her position she mocked the
green new deal and I agree with her yeah
so there's a lot of mainstream Democrats
that you know I don't care for
mainstream odder --it Republicans
Democrats I don't care about that my
concern is cultural politics
ground-level protests what do I see do
we have
far-right white nationalists in on the
Republican side of Congress well there
are some people you can level
accusations against Steve King got
removed for much of committees but what
else do you have not not not too much
but the left is gonna claim Trump is he
isn't then you're gonna have on the left
you have Kirsten Gillibrand the future
the future is female intersectional oh
that's identitarian ISM I don't like
that you have Alexander Ocasio Cortes
green New Deal identitarian ISM you have
you on tomorrow she did sleep they're
all identitarian z-- so I look at the
left and I'm like all of these people
want to enact policy based on the color
of someone's skin I've experienced that
my life from the left and the right and
I do not want to live in that world
where I've had white people it you know
white supremacists vandalized my
family's home and I was little my mama's
explains to us that this is part of the
world people who don't like mixed-race
families I got Occupy Wall Street my god
do I did I get to experience the beauty
of being not white or or a person of
color because you're mixed yeah and they
the people on the Left say you're too
white you don't get to speak but I'm
mixed too bad then you have other people
saying I only will listen to you because
you're mixed I'm like well which one is
which who do i I hate it I hate all of
it I don't want it what do you think if
we were really doing like psych 101 on
this condition because I actually I'm
starting to think it's it's sort of like
a mental condition it's a mass mental
condition that's going on because it's
not based in fact so no matter how much
you you explain to these people that
you're for the individual and you want
everyone to live free and you're not a
bigot and the opposite of fashion and
all of these things in the opposite of
they're all sort of fascists then we
would ever be well the guy the guy the
verified guy who is calling me a fascist
today also tagged stitcher radio in the
tweet because they're they're my hosting
service now they don't host my podcasts
anyway we're released on stitcher on a
mega but I thought who's acting as a
fascist here me the guy defending Andrew
individual rights and freedom or the guy
who's attacking me calling me a fascist
and trying to get me booted off a pile
this is one of those has more fascism in
it than I I think it to assert at a
certain level that it was partly an
accident but partly on purpose that this
this culture came to exist people who
are racist realized people hate racism
what do you do claim to fight racism and
empower racists so what do we see anti
flush has been Portland screaming racial
slurs at police screaming racial slurs
at that there's you know criticize
Patriot we're all you want they've said
as hadn't done really awful things in
in terms of there have been videos of
tiny punching someone starting a fight
I've seen it all but at the same time
you point out the people who run pate
repair are not white so when white
people show up white progressives
claiming they're anti-racist screaming
racial slurs at police screaming racial
slurs at conservatives by all means have
your disagreement with that group but
I'm pretty sure you were the racist with
that you buy your own standard that's
what I mean about a massive ental
condition because you know Brett
Weinstein when the whole thing was
happening at evergreens then he kept
saying I thought this was the most
fascinating part of the whole thing
beyond the absurdity of you know being
called a racist for not wanting the
school to be segregated putting that
aside yeah he said that the students
that he actually feared were not the
minority students it was the white
students behind them who had that look
of you know we've got the bat and we're
gonna call you there because they have
to really prove it right they have to
really prove it they are a form of white
supremacists and this that's why kinda I
just went this way for years you have
the what's called like a right wing
white supremacist these are people who
believe that white people should be
supreme and that they try to accomplish
that and do you think these people have
any insted said no I mean look they're
they're absolutely some people in power
who hold these views I think would be
absurd not to think so but I don't think
I don't think it's just widespread as
the Left tries to claim it is like it's
not being taught at universities now is
it yeah okay but here's the thing
the left white left left wing white wing
left wing white supremacy is the idea
that why people are supreme and so you
end up with over with with white people
believing they're the white saviors that
must force other white people to do as
they're told and so it gets really weird
then when these left wing individuals
who believe that white people are
supreme tel minorities what to do white
supremacists yeah you know I've told the
story a couple of times we'll do a
couple more minutes here and then we're
gonna do a Q&A so get your questions in
on super-tight right now but one of my
real wake up moments to all of this I
was on T YT once and you know they were
playing a clip of Fox News and and you
might know David Webb who's a
conservative who happens to be black
yeah and we were following that's right
we were friends from our old SiriusXM
days I'm used to go out to dinner and
have drinks and ever whatever and one of
the hosts a white progressive who didn't
know David him nor know knew that I knew
him kept saying that he's the token
black guy he's
and it's like he's the Uncle Tom he's
whatever you want to call it and that
was one of the first moments for me
where it was so obvious what it was yeah
cuz I know David and I know he believes
what he's believed David's the one that
he was on with Areva Martin who's a
progressive also and she enjoys life
right so I was like oh yeah she called
him out for his white privilege and then
he goes he goes well I'm black and then
she goes my people gave me the wrong
information as if as if I it's true like
oh he's being too as a white guy
everybody during Occupy Wall Street
there was an argument about the merit of
work or something I said a few things
and was told as a white person I didn't
understand and my opinions you know were
invalid because I could never understand
being a marginalized person and then I
said I'm actually mixed-race and the
response was oh oh I see what you're
saying now no no I get it now and I
laughed I'm like I'm like you're racist
yeah like you'll only listen to me
because you think I'm not white like
you're a racist when it's the soft
bigotry of low expectations also it's
like would you ever want that like how
many goddamn deal I would never want
anyone to give me anything other than
equality which you don't give me so so
amber tamblyn there's a story that was
out today or yesterday about Amber
Tamblyn saying she's not gonna vote for
Bernie she wants support a woman and she
said something like we now have a choice
and to me I thought that was crazy I'm
like as much as I am excited for the you
know people of color and women who are
running for office I certainly think
that their perspectives will bring a
unique you know value to our political
climate I wouldn't base my my vote on
the color of their skin or their gender
but here is someone who actually says
Bernie you're great but woman and I'm
like that doesn't mean your ideas are
good yeah it may be there's there's a
certain perspective you might hold it
might be valuable if that's expressed I
would vote for the expressed perspective
but I'm not gonna be like I won't vote
for a men what are we gonna do with what
a female Hitler emerges are you gonna be
like well it's a woman I know you're
gonna vote for a we talk like it's crazy
well I hate to tell you this is the
Bernie guy but they're coming for birdie
I mean at the end of the day by the next
year and a half of an election Bernie is
the old white guy at the is what he BR
is and he will be done and destroyed by
his end cream this is why and that was
the thing in a weird way in 2015 this is
important story I was walking with one
of my co-workers at fusion frothing at
the
about how much I loved Bernie I was
ranting loudly like going through all
the things he said and done here's the
important thing people to realize in
2015 Bernie Sanders says an open borders
that's a coke brothers proposal he says
his free trade agreements destroyed
manufacturing this country we need
stronger borders illegal immigration is
bad because it's hurting the middle
class and the lower class and I'm like
he also talked about student loan
forgiveness expanding programs he's a
little too left for me in a lot of areas
but I was like this is a guy who means
it it's one of the first times but more
importantly out of out of everything he
was saying
gun issue it's an urban versus rural
debate I'm like wow that's true there's
a very dramatic difference in
perspective he's like this guy's telling
the truth what happens once he gets on
stage white people don't know what it's
like to be poor whoa whoa whoa Bernie
that's pretty good that's I wasn't even
trying I'm like that that's not true
what's going on here then he goes we
must get equal pay for women and I'm
like we we have three laws in place
already Bernie what you doing now I'm
looking at the future we're in and I'm
like Bernie decided to endorse Hillary
and he and he started pushing this at
this narrative that has stepped him he's
it's backfired on him now they're saying
I won't vote for a white men sorry
Bernie my ingress Mike there you go
that's what you got so right man with
three houses so I will say this though I
would I
I still lean in his direction I I do
think it's a little further to the left
than I am but I even after all these
things if I was going to vote and I'm
probably won't because I don't trust
anybody if I would vote he still has
some brownie points from me I still I
still do like him but I think he's kind
of he should've endorsed Hillary he
shouldn't have pushed the identity and
stuff and that really really pushed me
away from him it did so I'm taking a
close look at Tulsi Gabbard right now
and I don't know if there's anyone else
I'd actually be interested in and I
don't know a lot about Tulsi so I don't
want to say like I definitely would vote
for but there's there's a lot of things
I like about her in terms of
anti-imperialism no intervention in
foreign wars and things like that
that sounds very trumpian too well but
it's it's libertarian right so that you
can be a right right libertarian left
libertarian the the difference is what
really bothers me is people always show
the political compass and they say an
tyfa is left libertarian then is not
true ant if i uses violence to force an
ideology onto other people left
libertarian are people with dreadlocks
and peace symbols they're sitting on a
beach going you know whatever and they
want to be left alone
but they're cooperative so
anarcho-communism it exists it's simple
it's ten people who live in a farm and
one person grows corn one person you
know cooks meat and they just share and
there's no real debate about who's doing
more than the other there's no
quantification of the value
anarcho-communism works really really
well in small groups it works really
really bad when you have to connect
different communities to each other and
quantify the amount of labor versus the
value being given in which case currency
becomes extremely important and
communism doesn't work at large scales
without killing millions of people and
getting into it so it might not be the
perfect solution for absolute it's
absolutely an opulent system of three
hundred fifty some people with different
thoughts and the annoying thing to me is
I believe in a mixed economy you have to
have aspects of a free market you have
to have some environment you have some
regulatory controls I believe social
programs are important because the
laissez-faire capitalism in my opinion
results in runaway corporations and then
fits it's no flex in an avalanche right
so I often use the Clean Water
Restoration Act as an example this the
cream the Clean Water Restoration Act
came out and I could begin my day to
wrongs been fifteen years I worked these
environmental organizations after a
river and Ohio started on fire because a
bunch of different companies were
dumping pollution but it not not very
large levels so individually they look
I'm not doing anything that's we're
pretty it's an it's a minor amount you
needed someone to look at the bigger
picture and be like guys it's on fire
and it's because all of you together
make a big problem
so social contract was formed and
everyone agreed to it and there's
someone to enforce it so I'm able Eve
you know that's where I get with
regulation but that's why I believe
unchecked capitalism results in
unfortunate veering off in random
directions which can cause problems
right yeah all right so that's so let's
just let's just do a little bit of
YouTube before we go too far
politics wise right it's a little more
on YouTube and though and then we'll do
the Q&A so what do you make of what's
going on on YouTube because I get people
every day now and I'm not talking about
the trolls and the reddit losers or bad
I'm talking about real people who I know
I mean it's often people that I've met
at events you email me and say Dave I
got on subscribed and Channel I call out
YouTube on it all the time once years
ago I had an email address of someone at
YouTube they actually gave me an email
address and someone at YouTube told me
there was a bug on my channel
then when I followed up they stopped
responding and then actually they told
me tonight oh yeah yeah and didn't you
have like a live stream locked in place
was that you oh yeah we had only the
live so if you would go to my my home
page you know youtube.com slash Reuben
report the video on the front would
always say yeah the Reuben report is now
live even though we weren't so people
would just well click away point is
without getting into all the bugs or
just cry me a river so all of this [ __ ]
all of this [ __ ] that we all kind of
know unsubscribes videos not going to
feeds the d modernization they d
monetize my video with peter Bogosian
and James Lindsay about but it's really
complicated oh yeah so I'm just I'm just
shoveling stuff at you I made a video
Jon Stewart praise the Trump
administration over the handling of the
9/11 Victims Fund made a video I said
Jon Stewart praises Trump over 9/11
Victims Fund and the point of that video
was I agree with John Stewart
wholeheartedly cut the politics out
these are people who sacrifice their
lives to save lives and I fully agree
with doing everything we have to to take
care of our first responders the video
was doing well but it listed no views
until I took 9/11 out and changed it
with first responders mmm all of a
sudden the views reappeared I made
another video about a woman a Muslim
woman from Egypt who is being berated by
another woman in a parking lot and the
point I was making with that video is I
typically don't make videos about this
because these people are being shamed
already it's like of course I don't
agree with running up to a Muslim person
and screaming at them and so this poor
woman I I'm holy in her defense and that
was throttled to an extreme degree
probably because it was about you know
Islam or Muslim or something and so
first I'll say hanlin's razor never
attribute to malice which is he's
explained by incompetence the deep
monetization thing is rant as seemingly
random so my mom makes math videos they
get demonetised nothing in them it's
like two plus two is four and it's
demonetised
yeah I mean I made a video where I went
to a raccoon cafe in Japan with my buddy
Luke and we're literally just feeding
raccoons and giggling while hokey family
music plays because I thought it'd be a
fun video to make demonetized
so so I get that a lot of it could be
random and it could be just you know
just ineptitude and all that the one
that I just mentioned though where it
already had a couple hundred thousand
views with Peter and you know we're
talking about the circle hooks and all
that it's it's all about academia I mean
this is
something that couldn't have an ad on it
it got through the algorithm and it was
monetized at first and then it was
manually confirmed manual review review
on monetized then I had to fight it
publicly and they monetized it again Wow
that's yeah so that but that's the
second time which is evidence that's
what I'm saying the reason I'm the
reason I always do this is because this
is the only course if I don't like doing
it but it's the only course of action we
have and this is then where I think some
of the lefties would say and now some of
the Trump people would say government
regulation they own all the pipes they
own all the information okay so I'll say
this um I said earlier I would welcome
regulation against Twitter because I
believe it's becoming so detrimental
especially after talking to Jack and
vijaya that that really tells you how
the conversation went well they look me
in the eyes and said we are going to do
what we think is right we are an
unelected listen twitter is an unelected
Council of the uber elite millionaires
who are dictating what people can or
can't say on one of the most important
public platforms in our country in the
world who determines they should have
that influence over our elections I
don't like Citizens United
and yes I understand the nuances with
you know taking away the right to speech
their money means that mass media
companies will hold too much power it's
complicated I don't want billionaires
dictating our elections I don't want
oligopolies forming and I certainly
don't want Twitter joining their party I
see them say this and I say you know
what maybe the best thing would be a
sledgehammer right now because the
debate is is basically over they said
they said basically we allow speech on
our platform if you follow our rules
well we know what people are getting
elected through your platform and you've
excised a large portion of the
population knock it down
here's a problem regulation wouldn't
actually work on YouTube or any other
platforms because you can't regulate to
create technology the government can't
go to YouTube and say you must invent
something something just happened
recently in Canada
well no but they could say you could you
have to treat all traffic equally you
have to ensure it's impossible I'm not
saying they should wait what do you mean
so YouTube absolutely impossible Twitter
it's more possible because Twitter could
just Timeline out like everything as
chronological we're done yeah a bannings
will based on first amendment YouTube
but when you go to youtube.com there's
15 videos they show you that
you can see there's 10 and then there's
another bracket below which usually is
like a single person's channel they have
to have an algorithm to determine what
they should feed you otherwise no one
gets any content fed to them at all
right so I get it it's not in a purely
chronological feed that doesn't work
that way but there could again I see I'm
not for this so it's hard to it's hard
to take this position but if the
government came in there is something
they could say that would probably make
it fairer I would not be for this oh so
you so what's the motivation you have no
right to an advertiser YouTube is acting
as your agent I see absolutely and I
still get a little bit when it comes to
promotion the YouTube algorithm right
now is probably one of the best
meritocratic systems for content if your
content is good like I've had I've had
unprecedented growth like in my career
with YouTube it took me years I've been
doing this for you know what in eight
years now and I gained I hit a hundred
thousand subs in like three months of
actively being on YouTube it took me six
years to get that on Twitter because
Twitter is about as people gonna talk
people gonna share your content well
what works on Twitter is rage anger
calling someone a not so you'll get
retweets yeah that gets you followers on
YouTube it's making compelling content
so YouTube's way better in my opinion
the government will not be able to
regulate YouTube into working better
they won't so regulation won't work for
Twitter I'm sorry what worked for you -
it will work for Twitter and Facebook
YouTube could regulate could be
regulated in certain capacities like
monkey Jones deserves every shoutout I
get possible whenever I do a video his
channel was deleted without breaking any
rules he made really edgy content he
made fun of elliot rodger that's that
shooter that insel shooter and it was
very clearly mocking the sky but for
whatever reason YouTube said terminated
his channel and I I still I still think
it's important to point out YouTube does
better than most other platforms in
terms of protecting the rights of speech
I really do believe that because I'll
give you an example
Sargon said a naughty word on YouTube
it's still there it's still there
patreon banned him yeah so YouTube was
like this video is not stripped of any
rights or anything we understand the
context so I can respect YouTube still
pointing out monkeys ban was insane and
terrifying yeah anyway I
with you that I would chalk a lot of
this up to just general ineptitude or
Jam but the thing has become so big you
know it's a Goliath now and well you
know maybe you can't it can't withstand
its own thing and the political forces
and everything else but I'm still I'm
still not for regulators any of them but
but it's an interesting you can't write
discussions with many people and it's an
interest high station to have YouTube is
also really important for elections but
the system the algorithm is it's
meritocratic meaning well what if you
knew tomorrow that within the algorithm
they were doing something to limit the
scope of your videos the ability for
your own subscribers I have three videos
so you have three channels or they were
making sure that your people were being
unsubscribed or a series of other things
that there is often much evidence to
believe it's happening what god and then
what do you do had your bets
i this is why i started a second channel
and now i'm launching sub verse i
recognise that trying to make a living
just off of youtube alone what is it is
it a safe bet because i've seen the past
it's not just us that's been affected by
this yeah there are people who just not
even for political reasons YouTube will
say we need to change the algorithm for
X reason and then all sudden someone's
traffic drops by 80% so I recognize
there's politics behind a lot of it I
trust that YouTube for the most part is
trying its best but I do think that
they're gonna take a utilitarian
approach in that monkey Jones the Lita's
channel even though you break any rules
because he's a threat to us mmm that's
that's BS and that worries me a lot but
but ultimately I think the only thing
you can really do is make alternate
channels and keep trying to figure out
and evolve you can't just you can't just
cross your fingers and hope YouTube
because here's the thing look
youtube.com has 15 videos and that's the
majority of most people's content when
someone goes youtube.com your videos
there YouTube has no obligation to
promote you when they do that and
there's no guarantee your content will
always fit what the algorithm wants so
you you make content your you know your
your your skyrocketing I think are you
over a million yet you're really close
to a million we were right under it but
I probably would have been there a year
ago but yeah yeah so you're doing really
well everything's working but because
your content is the same YouTube changes
the algorithm like please at several
times a day one
your traffic might just vanish and it's
not political and you won't know why
right so it's that it's the sort of lack
of transparency and maybe there's
interesting arguments why they're a
certain see when they when they were
more open with it it was all gamed and
the videos were awful like I remember
back in the day it would there would be
a video called like it you know
something stupid like big beautiful man
bouncing on beach balls and you click
and it's a black screen yeah cuz they
just want you to click it well I mean
yeah I started this show on t uit and
that's what they taught us how to do all
of the worst type of clickbait I mean it
is I don't even not even I'm not even
besmirching them that was that was just
the game that they taught us how to do
the worst type of click mate there's a
reason why there's so many videos worth
like ben shapiro destroys yeah with
logic and facts it's because that
structure was working for the algorithm
and still does and for the most part the
structure of like an all caps word i do
it too it's because youtube finds it
acceptable to just emphasize a word you
can't do a bold but and you can't convey
emphasis on words through text without
doing a capital or something so that's a
technique that works in the algorithm to
get people to like pitch the word and
emphasis is important in conveying the
meaning of your sentence so long yeah
whatever alright so let's just do one
other thing that will get to the Q&A
which is piggybacking off what you just
said so I can sense you're totally okay
basically with what's going on here
because you're growing like your
business is growing you're doing
journalism that you love you strike me
as one of the only sort of well journal
well what well I was gonna say am i I'm
okay with it
well no but my point being is like we're
watching all of the the learn to code
crowd that was trying to get everybody
all the the trolls or whatever band it's
like they're you know BuzzFeed's laying
off people HuffPo Gary to the editorial
staff boxes horrible daily beast is crap
like all of these I they're just giant
monsters of crap who have lied to
everybody for so long and and it's all
nobody cares about any of it but what
I'm watching right now and this is the
reason I'm hopeful is a just by the very
nature of what I'm doing and I'm very
proud of it and I think it's growing and
it's good I think I see guys like you I
see guys like Andy no Nick Monroe on
Twitter who doesn't interesting he's
doing action yeah he's leveraging
Twitter for actual journalism I'm seeing
people taking take technology use it
their own way Peterson and I are working
on this platform like I think there's so
much hopefulness
I've good news for you yeah give me some
good news before we do the Q&A one of
the main reasons YouTube takes action
against channels is because the culture
war these digital journalists who write
these absurd stories put pressure on
advertisers and then YouTube esta back
has to do something to stop the bleed as
these companies lay more and more people
off there's less people to write lies
about us yeah
and that means YouTube is less
constrained so you know I get really
frustrated people point the finger at
YouTube on things YouTube didn't do
wrong point the fingers of the things
they did wrong I got monkey Jones that
was wrong but a lot of issues like to
you monetization you people think do you
monetization is someone at YouTube put
on their mustache trying to take your
money away it's like no no YouTube just
lost their money too
they don't want to do monetize you if
they don't have to but they're they're
scared of these fringe identitarian
weirdos at these media companies who
want to call you in and sell and YouTube
is trying to do its best to make sure
there's this thing hit look you still
get YouTube read revenue when you can be
monetized 100 percent that is YouTube's
putting up a barrier to protect you from
these lunatics who are lying about you
so YouTube does things wrong absolutely
but they're doing better than a lot and
I truly believe that once these
companies collapse under the weight of
their own incompetence and other
cultural problems I think YouTube is
gonna be more free to be alike you guys
we got you you know so I mean look the
fact that you're allowed to exist doing
this yeah you speak truth to power in a
lot of ways you do things that would
never be allowed by some of these people
these media companies they've never
allow you to have certain people in here
to talk about these things
YouTube has opened the door in a lot of
ways continues to yeah and while they
have mistakes I'm hopeful because I know
people at YouTube I've known them for
years that they I think there's there's
absolutely an ideological bent to a lot
of people I do have some sources that
work within Google have shared
information that I don't think it's as
bad as a lot of people think it is I
think there's there's some points work
it's really bad the far-left
identitarian ism within the company but
there's a lot of really hopeful things
in the area of free speech and
protecting rights that I think Google is
aware of that other companies don't care
about yeah well I'm glad to hear that
that's a nice way to wrap up this first
half that we're doing here and I would
just add to that that yeah
I'm incredibly appreciative of YouTube
look look my life is [ __ ] amazing
because it is absolutely it this is
great I love detective right so when I'm
fighting it when
I always say I'm tired of fighting you
guys and it's like give me I don't have
an email address give me you know but
you know you know and it's like if you
guys would just be a little bit better I
think they'd get a lot hired so don't
understand why at this point for you
especially YouTube doesn't just unlock
everything like they what do you think
I'm gonna do tomorrow
right no but but they're there there
have been conversations about giving
people the option to choose you monetize
themselves trusted trusted high-profile
like your Dave Rubin like they can look
at your videos they know exactly what
you're gonna do and all these talk shows
it is a talk show that is in line with
almost any other kind of talk show you'd
see on TV that has normal advertisers I
don't think there's gonna be a big you
know like you you're you're not even
like Tucker Carlson who has like
activists coming at him because you're
not even anywhere near where he is so
I'm surprised YouTube hasn't come to you
and says we think you're good to go
period they should I believe a system
for you should be inverted it should be
that right now your video could see
monetized you asked for a review what
should happen is your video should be
monetized and they should have to choose
to review you because your trusted your
your your studio Dave Rubin mainstream
conversation but it is it's it's this is
the other thing too is it's important to
recognize and I hope YouTube does too
they need to create these protections
because what you're doing is the is the
new mainstream talk-show right the
television networks are doing really
well but these digital outlets not so
much in a lot of ways this is the
professional that you know five seven
years ago five to six seven years ago
YouTube didn't have this yeah it had
like I mean I remember the first view I
made it's like awful it's just so trashy
did you know it's news but I had no idea
what I was doing the quality was trash
but I got half a million views yeah
because YouTube didn't have this now
YouTube actually has a there's a guy in
YouTube who does live high profile talk
shows about political issues that have
serious ramifications on our culture and
you've got a beautiful set and you're
not the only one so YouTube I'm sure
they know this and at this point why why
is Seth Seth my what's who's the night
late-night talk show host night Seth
Meyers yeah he's a preferred partner and
you're not they give him special access
they don't give you that's ridiculous
but if YouTube wants to see their
platform grow then they need to start
coming to people like you and they do
this to a lot of people
but they absolutely need to come and
give special protections and and you
know prefer to access not just to the
mainstream cable channel guys you know
what I mean now I owe you five percent
of the monetization of this video if it
gets monetized all right here's we're
take a one minute break and then we're
gonna do super chat questions get them
in right now we'll read them live and do
our thing for as long as we can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back
I think that was record time yeah we
peed in different bathrooms real fast
though yeah imagine ran out the door the
magic of YouTube ah right here we go
before anything else this Friday if
you're in the LA area I'm at the ice
house comedy club it's Friday March 8th
it's me
stand up mess around the crowd audience
Q&A bringing an IDW member there's a
rumor that maybe Tim Poole will be there
for the hell knows we'll see what
happens
ok here we go I got a zillion questions
here keep throwing them in on on super
chat we'll get to as many as possible
Tim you're an amazing example of
journalistic integrity I'm glad your
channels are getting traction the fact
that you stuck to your principles even
when thinking the feed was down was
amazing referencing the Rogan brand do
you think vijaya was rep referencing
abuse and harassment honestly or was
this ideological doublespeak so a lot of
people were frustrated with her because
she kind of talks like a lawyer yeah and
in the nature of when she's conversation
she is a lawyer and that makes it tough
I think she believes what you saying I I
think you like look what it comes to
ideology III don't think Jack and vijaya
are lying about what they truly believe
is right I just think they don't realize
their wielding a giant sword and no one
ever gave them that like that they have
no right to that power so is there an
immediate plan for Twitter to remove
lifetime bans and form a review process
where the Sargon's and milos of the
world that seems to have got they they
mentioned it being in the pipeline or
something to me that sounds like it's
never gonna happen yeah you know that's
- Tim I know you are a rather unassuming
guy I'd like to say that you're a very
good reporter and have unimpeachable
integrity keep up the good work that's
not even a question I am gonna read nice
things I'm right I am not perfect I you
know I see all these things
complimenting me I'm like I was just
saying what I felt and I also feel like
you know people like to call me
objective and all these things like dude
I am I can I told Joe listen I'm a
centrist partisan you know I clearly
support certain values and integrity
integrity integral principles these are
the things
that led to me to do journalism the way
I do I don't want to act like I'm better
than anybody else I don't know yeah okay
do you think Twitter should or does hire
people like yourself that keep an ear to
the ground or they can simply hire a
team to intake media like yours
there were many cases where they pled
ignorant to current event so it's a lot
to cultural events it's a lot of that
that it's just you know we're pushing
and I I asked them why don't you open an
office in a conservative area they said
well our our trust and safety team is
global I think ultimately what happens
is they're trying to decide what is or
isn't right and they think they're
smarter than 200 years of history and
precedent set by our institutions and
our founding fathers and our ancestors
they're not but they believe they are
it's a level of arrogance that is in my
opinion it's normal human arrogance and
it takes a certain understanding of
philosophy to say I can never know
what's right for for hundreds of
millions of people I need to break up my
power and disperse it Jack seems to
understand this concept when he talks
about distributed networks and
blockchain stuff and I wonder why then
he won't say you know the power that the
Triforce of Twitter needs been fractured
and sent out in different directions
that's what the power needs to be
distribute it's too much for one person
so you're saying that perhaps the
distributed social network could be the
solution to some of this only if some
people were working on something like is
that what is that what I'm just reading
questions here well I will add yeah
that's been that's that's like I think
you're in a race right now with a ton of
other people yeah like it's a beautiful
thing I love that race right there there
was - bro yeah if you're familiar with
that bro
I mean people sent me links to different
and now we obviously Minds is trying to
create it's a real interning model it's
it's got a central nucleus with semi
decentralized which could work and I've
been using that for my group organizing
so no we'll see you know yeah well look
that's beautiful thing let the
competition go and then maybe some of
them will end emerge competition is
great yeah that's what it's all about
thanks for the stream fellas okay hey
Ruben do you think
oh hey Ruben hey Tim do you think that
Trump will ever do a live stream with a
youtuber also Tim thanks for your
reporting much appreciated I think
eventually he will I think he's still
like I hope he will come in here and it
will be bananas and Oh Mike if I ever
thought I got hate it
you know rayon to a whole new level but
my feeling is that eventually he's using
the mainstream media as their perfect
rock and a hard place thing as long as
he can and eventually something will
shift the symmetry will shift and he'll
have to do something you know the
challenge for me is on Trump is like I
can criticize him all day but the media
literally does that non-stop 24/7 I feel
like I'm not adding anything the
conversation to point out why I agree
with why they criticize him yeah I also
think it's insane that Trump derangement
syndrome is a serious problem you can
clearly look at the things he's done
that are working yeah and not be a
lunatic and you could like it's whatever
I want to get on Trump I will rant I
work for a major newly acquired tech
company I'm a senior engineer not many
people are savvy to search algorithms
how do we verify that our data is
factual in an era where ours where our
sensors are few but powerful I mean this
comes up all the time right it's like oh
it's you can I mean look
Wow you know people you have a group of
people who trust the mainstream media
and Glenn Greenwald tweeted I feel sorry
I genuinely feel sorry for the msn you
know he was referencing I MSNBC viewers
who for years have been told Trump is
working for Putin and all stuff and now
that we're hearing the Muller reports
gonna be anticlimactic and is probably
nothing in it
they're they're losing their minds like
oh no our narrative what do you do like
well you can't you you can't trust
anybody it's insane I'm surprised I
don't know what to tell you man I'm it
worries me I stay up at night sometimes
someone gave us $4.99 and pounds on
super chat and they said get mr. Poole a
drink on me dude killed it on Rogen what
do you what do you drink not alcohol you
don't drink any okay well i yesterday i
had some beer after the roben thing and
i had deep-fried Oreos with ice cream so
that was like that was fun we I went out
and I had a beer and I didn't finish it
I drank about half of it I can't I can't
I used to drink too much when I was
young I just can't drink anymore it just
doesn't work for me well this is a paleo
house there are no Oreos in here but
there is beer no beer you think about it
you can't about it like okay
satay peanut sauce from Tim I don't
agree with your politics but I love how
this discussion went or how your
discussion went on Joe Rogan's podcast
well done sir they just saying nice
things where are the people who hate me
let's see okay we're give you money
the word fascist hence Nazi is among the
fighting words not protected does this
change either of your minds about these
terms Chaplin skeevers New Hampshire I
mean I I don't believe in hate speech
period so I think you with the exception
of the very tiny tiny limitations on
speech you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater called call for direct violence
and I think you'd do what everyone so
even though those guys were calling us a
Nazi today I'm not actually for them
getting booted the only reason I was
sharing it was to show the idiotic
double standard exactly the interview if
Twitter wants to claim they're trying to
prevent us from leaving the only reason
I haven't left Twitter is because I'm an
adult who understands them in the world
people say mean things yeah but there
are some people who are not emotionally
mature enough and I think there's are so
according to the more in common document
by the hidden tribes group using YouGov
data progressives are like 8% they're
overwhelmingly white they tend to make
that they're more than twice as likely
to make $100,000 per year what does that
mean you've got a bunch of well-off more
likely to be well-off white people who
haven't been in the real world who are
who have bulldoze are parents who have
cleared every ops about from in front of
them and when they go in the real world
they meet someone who says I just plain
don't like you and they go home it's a
real offense to them they've never
experienced that before yeah I was
homeless so I'll say this too when when
it comes to like what if I got banned
tomorrow when I when I went on when I
was on Rogan and I said the SPLC
hoping I hate chase bank is banning
people these organizations are doing it
and they could ban me too
I don't care you know what happened if I
got banned on every platform right now
I'd go kick on the beach have a coconut
and be like that I would honestly be
like I'm glad it's finally over I can
relax I am I am a hippie at heart lefty
libertarian and I want to sit on in in
the middle of nowhere under some trees
with a coconut and some buddies and just
you know making our own fire finding
their own food and I just want to be
left alone and that I have an
unfortunate something in my head where
I'm passionate to fight for these values
in our society I have told myself this
since I was like 18 the moment it
becomes too difficult I am gone and it's
just been this this ongoing passionate
drive I've kept going and it's kept
working and now for some reason I was
just in front of Jack Dorsey the CEO of
Twitter who the hell am I to sit in
front of this multi millionaire
billionaire whatever he's
well you are you're somebody doing what
you're supposed to do
I'm just think I talks about stuff you
know it's like but that but this is what
you're supposed to be doing I guess
that's what the event anyway but and
I'll say it again if if they all said
you know what Tim we're gonna ban you
out right I'd be like all right I'd get
my car now just oh my god you know I let
me tell you it sounds so awesome that
some days I'm like man I can't stop I
have to work I haven't taken a day off
in two years but sometimes I'm like the
only way I could stop is if they forced
me to that'd be so great
I go stay at the skate park for a week
just play some music with my kusa guitar
out there artists used to put you out of
your misery
[Laughter]
hey Dave and Tim loved the work you guys
knew Tim do you plan to report on the
SNC lavell in scandal in Canada I
actually don't know what that is I don't
know about it but that reminds me of
something I'm sorry I can't answer that
question but I did want to point
something out I forgot about earlier
when it came to why you can't regulate
tech companies into inventing things
Canada passed a bill that would require
Google to create a registry of you know
political ads so Google head okay and
terminated all political heads yeah you
can't invent something so I apologize I
can't answer that but you know okay do
you feel that the actors that you guys
mentioned earlier actually hold those
leftist opinions or do you feel that
they're forced to espouse those opinions
by their publicist out of desire to look
like the good guy you know there's a
piece that when I when I saw the the
thing with brie Larson you know what the
only thing I actually sort of felt like
she knows the movies not gonna do well
so it's like what do you do you get in
front of it by making now a comment
that's gonna flaming as the trolls or
yep yep so you so it's like it wasn't
that the movie wasn't good she destroyed
me like when she walked it back so I
think I think the issue is there's a
some youtuber made a video who might
have been pissed after right exactly
really school youtuber made a video
where Michael B Jordan is on the view
and they're asking about Black Panther
and he says you know look we're just
here to celebrate who we are we're not
trying to bring anybody down and he
brings up how in South Korea a bunch of
other people from Indonesia oh shut up
in traditional clothing and it was
really uplifting and everyone was happy
and this youtuber was like green
checkmark like oh that made me feel
really good when Michael B Jordan said
that we're celebrating who we are with
each other that's so awesome that's it's
a small world after all right so
Disney's singing and happy Barry Larsson
does the head Bob
this movie wasn't made for you and I'm
like oh whoa why you were you doing like
that's mean and then she also has a
bunch of tweets where she's like a TSA
eight I simply looked at a TSA agent has
my phone number and I'm like oh come on
man
like dude yeah I get it but can you
please you know yeah for liberals on
Rogan debating whether Twitter is
sensitive censoring conservatives and no
conservative invited to discuss some
really really good points is how
censored we are yep but but that's we're
actually actually a really really good
point I have no I have no response other
than yep I mean look it was it was
authoritarian left versus libertarian
left talking about the banning of
libertarians and I don't mean big a
libertarian yeah so I think one of the
things we should clarify too is the
debate isn't about conservatives are the
most mostly getting the brunt of this
but there are libertarian left it's
really about the authoritarian left
there's no real authoritarian right
other than like well I don't want to
name any of the mainstream politicians
who fall into that category
yeah it's Democrats too I'm not I don't
even know who that would be really I'm
not gonna say it but it's it's it should
be fairly obvious the mainstream
corporatist Democrats they're
authoritarian right as far as I'm
concerned they've always been they are
not in line with Bernie Sanders they
hate Bernie Sanders they hate Tulsi
Gabbard they hate the left libertarian
people who want to end the Foreign Wars
so you know anybody who's in favor of
taking corporate money taking thirty
thousand dollars from Goldman Sachs but
right before they announce so they can
use that money and they're in favor of
military industrial complex foreign
bombing in other countries that's
authoritarian right and that's that
includes Democrats and Republicans fair
enough yeah
what is worse someone like Alex Jones
who you know is exaggerating on things
or BuzzFeed who lie but pretend to be
honest and the good guys feel free to
come back to Australia any time I gladly
will I think we're gonna do it next year
all right Alex Jones made a statement
that was read out by vijaya that I
believe was indefensible he said he was
encouraging people to do things
politically and even criminally and get
your battle rifles ready and I
understand you you know if it's supposed
to be a joke or metaphorical or whatever
but he did say it and you have to
recognize he's got a huge audience
people will take that literally and he
can't do that however that was a
one stream action BuzzFeed is doing
haymakers I did a video on my youtube
channel where I explained what what you
got an uppercut a powerful boom to the
face and then BuzzFeed doing small jabs
over and over again
BuzzFeed was on the Covington you know
BS BuzzFeed even after it was proven
their story about Michael Cohen and
Trump was wrong for some so first thing
that went away quick didn't know they
what they keep defending it Muller
Muller came out and said the story
spanked what did was buzz we do nope we
stand by our sources Cohen testifies
Trump never directly told me to lie it
doesn't work that way no we were right
it's like you know I mean I mean it went
away not that the story went away I mean
that it just nobody really called him
out of the lab I was like yes it was it
happened on a Friday and by Monday it
was basically over it's and so you know
I'm curious I mentioned this too it's
one of the problems with bias right I
think Jack's a good guy I think he's
trying they didn't know who Jonathan
Morgan was they knew who Jacob Wall was
why right that was a good because the
journey journalists are like a it's
something like 72% of journalism jobs
are in blue districts so they're like
you Jacob wall Jacob wall Jonathan
Morgan a Democrat they don't well you
know even though he duped them even
though this guy it's report by the New
York Times that he was engaging in this
operation Facebook banned him for I
think it's fair to say this happened was
manipulating national reporters into
smearing a Republican they still just
kind of like they did were they report
on it that's fair but where was the
outrage from the whole Twitterati all
the digital media saying arm the
Democrats are meddling in our election
oh my god nap yeah
any did any of the verified journalists
or politicians or whatever who were
calling for violence or punched those
kids in the face or any of those people
did any of them get banned or suspended
so you know the only thing any comment
on is the the one guy I referenced over
and over again who said LACMA school
burned down fire them when you see them
he did get a suspension and was forced
to delete those tweets but I think it's
absolutely hilarious that you can have
someone like Chuck Johnson where he said
he was raising money to take out you
know D array and they're like ooo better
ban him perma ban no warning just done
and there was I could be wrong but I
believe there was a story about email
leaks where like some high up individual
was like just get rid of him then you
have the this other guy who's like lock
them in school burn it down well please
don't do this again
please like calling for the death of kid
versus insinuating you want to raise
money to do a hit piece on an individual
that was could be considered in a
certain way I get it I would have had no
problem if they said listen do you
understand why people might think you're
talking about killing somebody can you
take this down and okay sorry about that
no they were like whack yeah this other
guy just please just stop oh lordy Lordy
alright guys we're gonna get to as many
as possible just reminder I am at the
Ice House in Pasadena right here in LA
March 8th
it's this Friday maybe 10 we'll be there
maybe an ID double you know I promise
you an ID w I'll be there maybe I'll be
there
I assume the link is right down below so
check that out or it's Dave Rubin comm
slash events ok here we go my birthday
is the following day too so it's you
know well yeah that's why I'm staying in
LA for the week I'm gonna you know I
don't know how are you gonna be 33 33rd
birthday in LA it's good 3 3 this could
end ever you could end up with a coconut
and all right here we go although Vijaya
was forthcoming did you detect any
tactical dishonesty in how she spoke
buzzer damage control especially in
comparison to jacksie absolutely like
when I brought up learn to code they
prepared for it and she said it was
connected to harassment campaigns I know
a whole and then and that's there's only
a couple times I actually stopped her
like in anger I apologized for it
because but I'm like I have to you know
I want to give them time to answer
because I didn't want to just start
leveling all these things and throwing
them I wanted the people explain
themselves be fair but when she went
back on well it was a her and
the editor-in-chief of The Daily Caller
was not harassing anybody I was tweeting
a joke and you locked him out of his
account there's no explanation for that
and following the episode with Joe I got
inundated with emails of people showing
me that even when they were tweeting to
their friends yeah someone responded to
a conservative personality they said
Ella why this is a really great thing
and maybe this could help someone learn
to code spend it just joking a together
basis because basically I think what
Twitter did was they were lobbied by
activists activists who work for news
organizations they say it's not true but
I'm like I the journalists were targeted
in the first place by people saying
learn to code I can't imagine that
wasn't the case and they said just ban
everybody who's just algorithm it you
know just yeah all right I'm calling an
audible for a second because so we
talked about the
just sort of this the business model of
the media companies and why they are
crumbling but what do you make it just
the general state of journalists in
general I got mentioned some of the
journalists I like but there there are
so many these people that work at these
company they could never have another
job
like they could never don't have a job
in the first place yeah you know I used
to work for American air I worked for
American Airlines regional twelth
American Eagle lifting I believe around
something like 50,000 pounds per day
I've hurt my hand at one point doing
this labor I was making ten bucks an
hour and then when I for the first time
walked into a newsroom I went how much
are they getting paid per year you're
getting more than double what I got to
write about Brad Pitt's junk yeah what
is and then they're saying they're not
getting paid enough and I'm like wow you
know vice notoriously underpaid people
but I never really thought of it much
because I was like you're upset that
you're getting 30 grand a year like I
was getting 13 to lift bags and be
insulted and do back-breaking labor
covered in sweat all day this is
paradise and that's another reason why
I'm like I you really have no leverage
over me these people if they're
threatening me with banning I really
don't care you could take away my shoes
my pants and I have I have seen the
worst of the worst I have been the
favelas of Brazil I have been to the old
communist bloc housing in Ukraine I have
seen how bad things can really be and
all I look at when I see that the beauty
and comfort of America is spoiled brats
who are complaining about how bad they
have it wouldn't have it better than 99
percent of the world it's mind-blowing
to me freest country in the history of
the world it ain't that bad
Tim I'm so proud of you you stood your
ground and held their feet to the fire
Dave love you to fight on all right
that's a bouquet not another one I love
you here's a duck we got three I love
yous in a row that was just I love you
love you Tim been amazing to see your
rise please both of you keep defending
free speech and expression okay thanks
for doing this important job oh this is
an interesting one for you who would win
in a tag team wrestling match Ben
Shapiro and Jordan Peterson versed Dave
Rubin and Eric Weinstein you and you and
Eric I'm not trying to be a dick but Ben
Shapiro is on the smaller yeah but no
it's true I mean what Jordans got long
reach he's got long reach but then
you're you're a little taller than
average so you could you could probably
easily counter against Jordan if you put
some you know but but Eric he's got the
the curb weight he could easily he'd
crush Ben yeah he's
he's got the the white clay he's Meowth
classes you know both so I think you
guys together it's an unfair you know
the memes are already coming out this is
a good one well and I actually I was
gonna ask you this but I only saw about
80% of the whole thing yesterday cuz I
didn't realize it was on until I was why
didn't you ask about why Louis
Farrakhan's account is allowed man I you
know I'll be honest there was a bunch of
stuff that just I didn't get to I had
notes and I was checking them too and
there was just I felt like there was so
much and at a certain point - he's
they've addressed it and I don't know
there were a couple people that
afterwards I was like god that's a
really good point you know I just I'm
not perfect
a lot of people thought that I wasn't
the right person for the job I'm saying
look I see a lot of people praising me
like wow Tim was perfect for this
some people are sort of saying Ben
Shapiro should have been the right
person and I'm like yeah maybe I don't
know I I when Joe mean concern people
that were saying from the conservative
side saying you weren't being hard
enough yeah you didn't see there were
there comments from people and that even
like you know I'll say this too it seems
like sam Harris's fans absolutely detest
me I don't know whatever but there are
conservative people who thought it would
been better if Ben Shapiro was there
instead because you know maybe I don't
know I think Ben Shapiro is really good
at what he does and it's a good point
that he's a conservative and I'm not
while I certainly have tracked a lot of
this news maybe that would have made
more sense all I can say is I got asked
to do it and my response to to Joe was
Joe I'm a little burned up in a tree
that just got us down feathers and
you're kicking me out of the nest right
now by asked me to do this I'll do it
and he was like yeah come on man he's
like you're a smart guy don't mic let's
go you know so it's a beautiful thing
just doing what you're supposed to be
doing I guess yeah love both y'all I'm a
conservative and I have many strong
political differences with you guys but
I appreciate both of you for your
dedication and seeking the truth rather
than promoting politically convenient
narratives right on thing that you may
be the conspiracy is some organization
created the regressive left to unify
that like like your moderate liberal and
conservatives into a lion why do I keep
getting invited to conservative things
where I go up there I tell them all
these things that I did and they keep
inviting me back it's very bizarre you
know yeah I mean really if me and you
said you know right now if a progressive
organization not to mock us or no
whatever would invite us to a university
or something would you do it absolutely
all right so let's see maybe somebody
will invite us but that's probably not
has anyone looked into the contractors
Twitter uses to moderate tweets Jack
mentioned also to other social media
companies use the same ones Quebec could
that be part of the buys you know there
was an interesting moment where he said
the thing about they're looking into
allowing the user to have control of
whether the responses could be seen yeah
I thought that was interesting because
what I noticed is now that now that I'm
high profile every time I tweet I could
tweet a picture of my dog and I get a
million people in there telling me I'm a
not seeing them here a bit and you can
and they know that the worst that they
are to me the more likes it gets so the
idea of shutting down replies I think is
interesting but but then he sort of
walked it back because then he said no
we would let the users know click an
extra click right well that's that's so
so basically they're trialing a system
where when you tweet and someone
responds you can mute them so no one can
see it unless you go to the bottom and
like open up the muted post or whatever
right so I guess there's something
valuable here you can sort of push it
down then I guess Twitter the problem
with Twitter is is how do you get
rewarded on Twitter anger yeah insults
so I know some some people who were they
stupid regular journalists there's a guy
I used to work with when I would do some
guest hosting for a certain network and
he was a normal dude we got along we
have been through the same politics and
then he realized he'd gained followers
by replying to Donald Trump and what did
he do now it's like I look at his
Twitter I'm like what the hell's wrong
with you like that's I mean for sure
they say the same thing to me but
admittedly I think it's funny when they
to move on to another point when they're
like Tim you changed they claim on being
red pilled and then I made a video where
I like here's an article for 22 from
2012 where I was calling up black bloc
anarchists for getting violent and they
physically attacked me you want to tell
me my opinions have changed I'm sure
many of them have absolutely I look at
my videos but you can also go 2012 and
see I have always been at odds with
these people they hate my guts they
physically attacked me numerous times
during occupy because I believe in being
up I'll tell you exactly what happened I
film some people draining the out of a
tire wasn't intention I didn't seek them
out I just saw him and I filmed it it
came to me later and said if you don't
produce propaganda for us
we will stop you they wanted me
specifically to film the things they
would point to like only film the police
don't film us let us do our thing and I
said no I'm gonna let people know
exactly what's happening so they did I
was attacked several times and it's it's
but it's like to think that there are
people who are like I don't understand
what Tim is calling out an taifa oh no
it's like have you ever watched to
anything I've ever done like we there
there's a there's an article about me in
like some magazine was a picture of me
being held back by cops while I was
fighting a guy in black bloc in 2011 MMA
come on man well also the idea that even
putting all of that aside the idea that
you're not allowed to evolve or change
your opinions exactly sad and and and
there and like somebody there was a
recently a video where I was like Dave
Rubens opinion changing over time and
people are gasping and I'm like so you
took old videos of Ruben and then you
realize that as he got older he read
things and changed his opinion that
doesn't how was that literally every
week for the last five years you know as
I've changed out things I've talked
about it openly like but you know what
you don't really bothers me about I
think look I'll be honest I think
there's absolute criticism you that you
can be criticized for I think you're I'm
not Jesus right exactly
I remember watching when your videos you
had someone who was like very much like
on the left and social justice and I was
watching it and then like shortly after
I saw someone say that they posted a
link to like an older interview did with
like you know Jordan Peterson and they
said all Ruben ever does is talk to
conservatives and I was like you know
that unit it is they do the same thing
to me they only share yeah these videos
and they assume you're not talking to
people and I'm like go to his channel
just click videos I went there I'm like
who's this I'm like oh that person is
like kind on the Left someone broke it
down while it's on Facebook they took
literally every interview I've ever done
and it actually leaned mostly left it's
like a split between like slightly left
and a little bit libertarian and they
they do the same thing to me where
they'll take selected videos and then be
like look at this video Tim dead and I'm
like did you watch it yeah you know so
actually a really good example is back
when comedy was watching you don't watch
well so this is a really good point when
Comey was testifying a couple years ago
he I made the video titled did did did
James Comey lie under oath question mark
because conservatives are saying he did
liberals are saying of course not and
liberal friends were outraged that I
would dare make a video excusing him of
line I didn't in fact the video
concludes he likely didn't and here's
why the reason I pose it as a question
was so that I was neutral to both
factions I'm not gonna tell you what he
did or didn't do I'm gonna ask the
question if you're interested I can then
walk you to why I believe a certain
thing they were upset that I didn't acav
ideo outright defending them even though
I did yeah they wanted the title to
definitively say conservatives are
stupid James Comey is not a liar I'm
like it was a really neutral title but
they got angry about it bow forever man
or they're not gonna stay with ya yeah
as a fellow South Sider I watch your
shows because it reminds me of hanging
out with my buddies at the park what
parks did you hang out at keep up the
great work both venom venom venom Park
south west side of Chicago and West Lawn
Tim I'm so proud of you you stood your
ground and held their feet to the fire
Dave loved you to fight on ok
not another just generic I love you
thank you Andy thanks for doing this
important job thank you we already did
the wrestling ones thank you let me
scroll the other way kudos for
yesterday's podcast question is there
any politician openly discussing
anti-monopoly laws in the digital space
I'm looking at Twitter Facebook Google
Amazon and their kin de-facto monopolies
well I guess from nothing I'm not sure I
think I think you know when when right
but I feel like jump truck you know
Trump gets his opinions in from Fox News
like he literally will tag Tucker
Carlson and Hannity after he hears them
and I look I gotta be honest I don't
blame him I don't expect him he's a
president he's me he's doing work yeah
the life isn't once to apply he's not
doing work but I'm sure at the end of
the day turns on the news that's what he
hears and he tweets about it so he's a
few steps behind the rest of us so I
think he is concerned he mentioned the
executive order on free speech in
campuses I've seen I think Jonathan hate
was critical of it but Bert Weinstein
was positive so there's some debate here
but in when I saw Jack Dorsey testifying
before Congress they had no idea with
all they're talking about there was like
one good interview where the guy said
why is Twitter defaulting only
Democratic politicians when you sign up
in DC and Jack was like well that's also
but that's also why to me regulation and
we're have to get that far back into it
but it's like that's why that makes no
sense the idea that the government could
understand what
company would have to do a up like I pay
my property taxes on a California state
website it looks like prodigy well 1896
you mean like that they'd come in and be
like we know detect twitter twitter
twitter twitter much easier to regulate
because in terms of when you first sign
up you get recommended democrats they
could say okay get rid of that mmm-hmm
because that's favoring one side if you
can't solve the solution get rid of it
when it comes to actual content on
twitter it's a reverse chronological
feed you can still follow however you
want you'll see what they post when they
post it
well it's assuming they're not shadow
banning and doing a bunch we have
reasons so if that's the if the
regulation is twitter you must abide by
free speech as set forth by this as
precedent set forth by the supreme court
therefore you know if something is
illegal law enforcement take care of it
it'll be taken down with a lot like in a
lawful order or whatever that could that
could neck could work because twitter
doesn't have anymore
that's not super complicated they are
trying to do algorithmic feeds which i
think is a bad idea yeah no yeah geez
alright
do either of you agree with radios
banning michael jackson now in the wake
of leaving other that's why hasn't
Neverland I haven't seen it yet yeah I
haven't seen it I mean I've heard we
knew yeah well I mean South Park had to
how many episodes where Michael Jackson
was like you know yeah doing weird
things of the kids like you know
separate that from the artists do I
think brie Larson is snooty I do is that
the reason why I chose to skip capita
marbles weekend it's not it's because
you combine that with the marketing of
the film and I was worried I'd sit
through another last Jedi yeah so you
know with Chris Evans I really don't
like the things he posts he comes off as
someone who thinks he's smart and he's
not yeah like he used he uses obscure
small words to make it seem like he's
got a big vocabulary are you telling me
he could possibly be worse than Ruffalo
cuz Ruffalo is unbearable I don't hope
now I'm like oh but but you know I
separate that Emeritus yeah so Michael
Jackson was terrible and look you know
when you go back in time and start
making getting you know raising your
arms and wiggling in the air because
maybe it's cold outside its offensive
today you know you know I think it is
honestly it's because the left and right
mean different things depending on what
they're talking about economics or
culture far left and far right often are
used to refer in most instances I
believe traditional versus progressive
so the far left
the extremists and progressive culture
want to purge history it's it's what
it's what I believe it is in China what
is it I don't know but it was the
Cultural Revolution I think where
they're like let's get were the old and
build the new so they want to purge baby
it's cold outside they want to get rid
of old songs because they were offensive
even though we understand yeah era and
and we've gotten rid of these things
it's also the height of capacity to
think that all I mean youyou said this
earlier basically but to think that the
the thousands of years of human history
that it was also wrong it but you you
have somehow gain the insight well all
those morons before you couldn't figure
out and if only you had the power over
O&I people this is one of my favorite
points to make in this conversation the
in the so in English common law we have
the presumption of innocence and that's
act that that's actually in the Bible so
when you look at where our society is
today one of the most important tenets
of a free society liberal democracy in
our English common law the idea that we
would say it is better that ten guilty
persons escape than one innocent
sufferer is not an original idea from
Blackstone its Blackstone formulation
it's actually biblical in the story of
Sodom and Gomorrah and I believe is
named was a lot I so there's a lot of
people I know on the left where like the
Bible is hokey BS it's like I I agree a
lot of it as but also don't forget a lot
of our institutions today started there
and brought us to a certain point the
story was simple God was gonna destroy
Sodom and Gomorrah and he said for the
sake of fifty righteous people I won't
destroy it and then he asked what about
30 what about 20 and God said even for
one righteous person I will not destroy
the city and that taught us a long time
ago that Bible the the old the Old
Testament is full of crazy things we do
not want to employ today and modern
religions don't like modern Judaism and
Christianity do not adhere to like
stoning people but we do still maintain
the presumption of innocence and the
right to protecting the righteous you
know even if it means all the bad people
get to go free so the point want to make
is we built a society we haven't we
haven't just destroyed everything in our
wake we're not burning the bridge behind
us we're getting rid of the bad things
and keeping the good things and there
are people that are so extreme to the
left they want to destroy everything
baby it's cold outside is a classic song
we understand why I can make some people
angry but for most
it really doesn't it's fake outrage yeah
you know and they want to get rid of it
it's like we can keep these things and
the other important issue is to when it
comes to the like the statue debate of
Confederate statues I shall take a
rather centrist approach while we put in
a museum and then put a placard there
explaining what history was and why we
changed it because then you maintain
your history the statue is in a museum
where people can still learn about their
history and then people can say we've
changed Society but we always need to
remember our past I think that's a very
unfair position I would be for you could
just put you could even leave them there
in some cases and still put the statue
but at least you know put up a plaque
explaining there's a Looney Toons I
think of what maybe it was Disney a
cartoon was up on YouTube of historical
cartoons that were like blackface and
really and there's a disclaimer saying
please remember this was from a
different time and we understand why
these things are offensive and wrong and
to pretend like this didn't exist which
would be to pretend our racist history
also didn't exist and we don't want to
do that I agree yeah I absolutely agree
well so it's that they'll come for
everything you know the creator family
guide now are saying they're not gonna
make gay jokes anymore so what do you
say well you're not gonna make gay jokes
well you're still gonna make black jokes
so you can still go make Jude and what
can we do with it you know they want
they're not doing on who decided all
right in the sins well no no they are
like I think did they flip on that well
I think it was big news actually
it was fake news that they're getting
robbed who in the company producers were
like no no we're not we talking about
dear God I hope you're right but here's
the thing when a story broke they're
gonna get rid of a poo yeah
there was actually a backlash among the
regressive left I don't say the
regressive left but social justice
activists saying you're getting rid of a
strong migrant business owner like a poo
wasn't a negative stereotype yeah he was
a successful business owner of about
immigration he was homers friend yeah he
was he's actually the heart of it and
there's a whole freaking town there's an
episode about a proposition to send him
home it became a citizen it's work
so we've the quick a lot of phoebus
exactly a lot of people were like here
you have one of the most positive
depictions of an Indian American migrant
who successfully runs a business and
because some people are upset by it
they're gonna get rid of it when some
people actually appreciate it
yeah I'm curious though I will have to
just google this after but I think they
said it was real because then Hank
Azaria said he won't do the voice anyway
back to him and he's a white guy even
though he's the greatest
you know voiceover actor of a generation
as he said I
shouldn't have done it or I won't do it
they don't know they never return the
money right say hey not returning all
the game I'll do one more on that issue
you know why fake news will never stop
money you publish fake news story you
make all the money you issue our
attraction two days later you keep all
the money yeah alright okay let's do
we'll do two more Tim made a point about
how people are scared about appearing
racist and jumping ship to other
platforms this may be a double-edged
sword that breeds sjw thinking for the
people who stay on Twitter
overcompensating for their anti racism
resulting in shoe color equals racist
that's actually pretty interesting
like what words so the idea is that you
don't want to leave to go to say gab or
something like that people will say
you're racist yeah so then you stay on
Twitter and then over time I suppose you
sort of get dumbed down into just now
you still want clicks so then you just
do what you got to do it again I don't
know what I do know understand the
question what I do know is that gap is
growing the center is the center is I
got to say you know this enters
brilliant centers I know it just came
out through this extension that creates
a comment section for any website and
when I heard they're doing that I went
whoa that was really really smart it's
so simple now there is an issue in that
the value of Twitter for me is the
newsfeed
you don't care about the stupid opinions
of the crazy people but seeing the
breaking news is really important for me
it's one of my sources so gab doesn't
work for that gab gab is good for the
people who use gab and I also want to
stress too I don't care for the fake
news the best I could understand is that
when I did my research a study was done
found gabs hate speech is about 5% of
all posts Twitter's as 2.4 somewhere in
those numbers gab is not that much worse
and my understanding is it's
predominantly like Trump supporters they
got bad actors for sure yeah Twitter has
substantially more about actors well
what's that weird thing when the when
the guy shot up the the temple and was
that not Philadelphia oh the Twitter
user
yeah I'm blanking the the Twitter user
who did it rip you said he was a twitter
user but they had but all stories were
about his Gabba key because he was also
a gap user that was the pouch trying to
make he was on Twitter he was on
Facebook you know yeah all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask a deep dark one
right now to end this
but then we'll try to end it in a little
car no but I do get this question often
at public of things to Tim do you do you
think we could be looking at a potential
civil war or information war I mean I
guess we're in it well the information
war is happening yeah that's why I date
in societies lying about us yeah but I
think it's really funny when I mentioned
eunuchs I'll absolutely say yes there's
gonna be some kind of Civil War we may
be in it and it's funny most people
don't freak out because they understand
I'm not like a prepper I'm not saying
that we're gonna be you know all the
buildings will be destroyed and they'll
be like Syria I'm saying there's gonna
be some kind of insurgency you know we
had the guys show up at the school in
Eugene Oregon smash the patriarchy and
chill pulled out a concealed gun fire
two rounds at a cop
a week later protesters of the far left
came and said you killed their comrade a
week later someone planted a bomb at a
police station you know what a good
point by the way that these things were
extremely underreported because
absolutely themed there they were coming
from the left and then when the guy
planted the bomb and in Houston on a
statue and then tried to act like it
wasn't by drinking the explosive the
liquid you know he's using for it so we
had the escalation of violence we have
people marching through the streets with
guns
we now have far left and yes to an
extent far-right groups that it's
actually I'll say this I'm not super
familiar with the far-right groups that
are prominent in marching there are
right-wing groups that are marching
around and libertarian groups but you do
have far left communist factions that
are armed and marching around one
important point though is that I have
seen people associated with the left and
the right who are who have guns at
events and they have more respect for
each other than anyone else so it was an
interesting thing I saw it was a rally
in Texas there was a there was a
left-hand protestor a right-wing
protestor both armed and they were
laughing and smiling at each other
asking about you know because I think
the gun give him a common connection
they were they understood the importance
the training the discipline but the
point I want to make is I think we're
gonna see some kind of insurgency people
point to the Weather Underground and say
we had this before
my understanding of The Weather
Underground it was it was shocking oh it
was late night no people were around
well someone planted a bomb at a police
station in Eugene Oregon and they it was
real and it was during the day when
people were there and the guy mowing the
lawn saw it they to come in and deal
with it you know we so I think the
the nightmare scenario for me is for one
what are we seeing right now Chase Bank
shutting people down
only a couple accounts so far MasterCard
has shots I believe at least one person
maybe more I could be wrong patreon
Twitter banning people are moving to gap
but people are moving to - people are
moving to other platforms [ __ ] shoot so
I've talked about the emergence of a
parallel society on Twitter at least
right now like Jack Dorsey mentioned
Megan Phelps the Westboro Baptist Church
got to interact with people and it
pulled her out of the church they're
doing away with that they are
guaranteeing that the way it was it was
actually explained this so I mentioned
this but it was Joey salads the youtuber
who went through that whole redemption
process he said when you ban people
you're taken like some do - just smokes
pot and putting them in prison with some
murderers like what do you think is
gonna do those people so you've got
someone on Twitter who was banned for
saying men aren't women and then they're
like you're banned the only place they
can go is where there's actual white
supremacist and Nazis what do you think
is gonna happen to those people when
they're surrounded by this and it's the
only community that engages with them
and that's why I like to I like tell the
story of Joey I didn't infer them
recently when if you know Joey sales is
yeah he did that video where you hired
black people to smash a trump car yeah
it's horrible horrible terrible terrible
thing to do and when he tweeted at me
the first time I got so angry this fake
news guy cuz he represented the fake
news people I hated so much doing the
same thing and then I realized this guy
is trying not to be that guy anymore
if I don't let him he's gonna go back to
being the bad guy if you don't give him
a chance
and he got a chance and the important
thing here is he went from making this
extremist rage bait fake news racist
videos to like one of his latest videos
was him wearing a wig and using a bait
purse that sprayed someone with milk
like the most hokey pg-13 silly prank
and I'm like there you go the videos
he's making now are so mainstream and
normal and hokey he realized what he was
doing was wrong what he said to me was
he didn't realize how far he had gone he
kept doing it and doing it and doing was
getting worse and he didn't realize how
bad it was getting and then you know
it's only because he was able to come
clean and people let him he did get
banned from YouTube that now he's an
he's just there like probably a normal
conservative he makes silly videos where
would he be if he was banned he'd be
hanging out in the dark corners of the
web with the people who liked him being
fed constant negative and racist
opinions and
you are the summation of the people who
surround you so that terrifies me and
and what's even worse is Jack said I
fear that the darkness and I know it's
happening and that's when I said the
snowflake doesn't blame itself all of
these companies are doing it they are
creating so the reason I bring this up
right now is it may be early it may
never happen but we are looking at the
beginning mmm with banks banning people
with patreon with with social networks
and parallel networks emerging
subscribed stars a really good example
this is the formation of a parallel
economy yeah where people are using
foreign credit card processors now
because the mains then the American ones
won't do it now you've got people who
are completely in a separate economic
system and they can still interact for
the time being but what happens when
your credit card doesn't work anymore
and you can't go to any regular store so
now you can only go to certain stores
and these people aren't going to just
die they're not going to give up on life
they're going to say you people have
kicked me out I don't like you you're my
enemy you're gonna so it looks like the
pattern is obvious in my opinion if they
don't stop you will at least end up with
hundreds of thousands of people excised
from society if we're not already there
and what happens when they say I won't
have a rally they say oh these people
are coming from gab
they must be neo-nazis so they show up
with clubs and bets and what are you
allowed to do it no that's these exactly
and then these people come back so we
better bring guns to protect ourselves
there was already a guy I think it was
in Portland who when a bunch of
protesters were marching towards with
his hands up drew his weapon on him he
got charged he got in trouble but the
the here's the important takeaway on
whether or not a civil war will happen
when we read history it's condensed we
read in 1938 the seventh in 1939 this
happened but for the people who lived it
nothing happened yeah six months later
it was a slow gradual increase it may be
in a hundred years that they say wow the
second level civil war started you know
2016 after Trump got elected and and the
protesters showed up at his inauguration
that was when it all started were in it
we can't see it we're in the forest you
know we don't we don't realize so so but
look I once gave me negative positive
negative positive there what I mean oh
it's nice all native yeah what I mean it
was a positive was that when you saw a
guy like Joey salads you oh yeah yeah
there are good people out there willing
to the positive open up in the
the positive when it comes to Joey is
that he wasn't banned and so because he
wasn't he said I'm gonna do better and
he did and now he's making me silly he
he makes some pg-13 videos where it's
like you know pranks on my girlfriend
and stuff but it's like so dramatically
different from where he was getting out
of control and it's only because he
wasn't banned he was able to become you
know pulled back into the mainstream but
if they just get rid of him you think
they did you think he's gonna want to be
homeless and starving he's gonna try and
figure how to make money he's gonna go
on cryptocurrency he's gonna go hang out
with people who are willing to support
him and he was doing some stupid races
stuff so who you thinks gonna support
him we can't we can't have that we need
to welcome people back into society and
give them a chance to be part of the
mainstream in the norm I think we are
seeing the gradual like it's it's it's
it's likely in my opinion I think I
think we we don't we don't realize we're
in it we don't we don't realize we're in
a forest we just see trees around us you
know I mean I'm shame because we will
look back and for all the people that
think it's so bad and we all hate each
other these are the good old days if
that happens and I will do everything I
can to make it one criticism that I hear
a lot from people is that when I first
were on Rogan the first time and said
that what's going on Twitter is maybe
one of the biggest problems we're facing
today I saw Commons from people who hate
me who are like that's the stupidest
thing Tim pulls a [ __ ] he thinks
Twitter is that important Kevin Hart
lost hosting the Oscars because he
tweeted something the Oscars are a major
cultural event that was impacted because
of one joke he made on a platform so I
think to myself maybe it is exaggerated
and then I think to myself you know what
it actually is I'll give you another
quick anecdote I was driving down the
Roosevelt Avenue in Chicago going to the
suburbs and I looked at my mirror and I
saw a squad car and I said oh I should
get off the road right now you might
pull me over oh I'm being paranoid
he then turns him to the left turn lane
they put his left signal on he pulled in
front of me sped up and I thought to
myself he wasn't gonna pull me over
maybe I should get off the road legend
case man
he pulled me over so I thought from then
I was like maybe if my intuition tells
me that something's about to happen I
should pay attention to that and I will
say this too I I've been wrong about a
few things like I said I thought the
Republicans going to sweep the midterms
it was a bit mixed they took the Senate
and but I've consistently
we're gonna see more violence things are
gonna get worse and it's been it's been
sporadic so I don't I don't know if I
can say I'm right or wrong yet but I
think with the people marching with guns
with you know the ever-increasing
escalation of violence we just had some
proud boys plead guilty to the mob
violence in New York the it was like
gang bonds or something I'm hoping it's
not true I don't know the percentage
would be if I was gonna give it a
probability Eileen I would just say this
I believe it's greater than chance we
will have an escalation of civil
conflict continually and nothing's gonna
stop look when you when you I was
talking my brother about this if you
want to truly understand why you come to
the point of civil war conflict or
insurgency I want you to go to one of
these regressive leftists look them in
the eye and say a biological male can
never be biologically female and they
can't there is nothing in their brain
that will ever comprehend that I have
people from Occupy Wall Street who are
now posting on Facebook this guy said I
can't believe people think by male and
female are objective things that exists
I think these people are just stupid and
so I sent them some research and I said
look at these statistics intersex is 1.7
percent that's from the intersex you
know lobbying groups and he said I can't
believe you actually think this is real
you're you're crazy or just stupid and
I'm like if if there is something as
basic as I can actually look at a man
and a woman and know which one's the men
woman I can't actually look at the earth
being round without some special tool or
math yeah these people that tell you
that the Conservatives don't believe in
science - right and we know the earth is
round
we can't see with our stroke with our
eyes but we know it from our communities
and science I can look at a man at home
and tell you which one is which in not
every case I I respect that but if you
get to a point where there's someone who
believes so fundamentally that's
something that Israel isn't what happens
when it comes to when it comes to blows
what one of my favorite lines on this is
Douglas Mario I'm sure you're familiar
with yeah I I asked him you know what
what is he how does he envision this
sort of same question and he said you
know one day the barbarians will be at
the gate and we'll be debating what
pronoun to call them yeah well listen if
there's a little sliver of hope here I
absolutely think you're part of it and
watching you grow through this whole
freaking hole it's been it has been
awesome so let's keep trying to fix this
thing right
yeah I I just don't know what just don't
I'm not hopeful though after that
conversation with Jack I'm like damn not
hopeful it's it's it's new once there's
some things I think he listened to and
maybe he'll do right but I really feel
like all those lieutenants are smug
condescending arrogant we know what's
right we're gonna do it anyway I'm like
welcome to the tyranny it's the end for
more with Tim Poole it's it's just slash
Tim cast on YouTube yeah yeah yes
it's youtube.com slash Tim cast and you
gonna get a new beating one of these
days I actually know this is it this is
that one is new yeah it's on same one
I've just a bunch of different ones yeah
similar style different companies it
depends on the color of shirts I'm
wearing you know catch all the beanies
and all the truth yeah youtube.com slash
Tim cast all right thanks guys
[Music]